all right
circuit board of fairfax county is now
in session yo andy askaradi president
all right
good morning
everything good now judy we're good all
right thanks all right do we have any
preliminary matters before the jury
okay
okay
all right here are paper copies and the
thumbnail contains electronic copies of
these as well
okay well i kind of need a thumb drive
for each audio recording but oh it's a
separate thumbnail it's it's it's marked
as different exhibits so i have to have
it as different exhibits so
okay good we'll go through them and see
what we have
and you have yours as well uh your yes
your honor if i may approach okay um
okay perfect all right
great we'll go through those if we need
anything else we'll let you know okay
just because we can have them numbered
that way correct
all right i could keep trademe happy yes
okay all right thank you
okay sure
all right
so
so
hmm
all right thank you you can be seated
all right
just a reminder mr depp you're still
under oath okay sir yes yes all right
cross examination
all right
morning everyone i hope you had a nice
weekend
mr depp we've talked about this uh a
little bit but you've testified that
abuse can come in many forms correct
physical being one of them
right
yes indeed
emotional
indeed
verbal
indeed
psychological abuse
indeed
some of those sort of flew into the
other i'd like to talk
understood i'd like to talk about um
some of that abuse um can we pull up
exhibit 582 please
your honor this is a recording
defendant's exhibit 582 that we will
play um the entirety of
any objection to 582
no objection your honor all right 582 in
evidence
put your [ __ ] cigarette down on
someone else you [ __ ] have
consequences for your actions that's it
shut up fat ass yeah
you got me there
can you play that one more time please
michelle
objection your honor
i'll sustain the objection move on mr
depp and when when mr tells you in that
recording to go put your cigarettes out
on someone else you don't deny that but
instead you simply say shut up fat ass
is that correct
um i think that was another
grossly exaggerated moment of misheard
cyclone i did not put a cigarette out on
her or throw a cigarette at her let's
pull up exhibit 581 please this is
another recording that will play the
entirety of with your honor sleeve any
objection to 581 no objection 581
[Music]
i [ __ ] up and cried in my bedroom
after i had dumped you a [ __ ] week
week prior
a [ __ ] week prior after you beat the
[ __ ] out of me and then a week later you
show in my show up at my doorstep in my
room saying you want to say goodbye okay
say goodbye oh i said it yes you did sam
i'll go to the
text messages
so that we are clear because you said
before to me okay
no doubt but you did not
say
you're gonna come over to say bye i made
a huge mistake you didn't you didn't say
that to me
you didn't say ask me well i won't do it
again what's the mistake then didn't did
you or did you not say you're coming
over to say
bye can we please pull up exhibit five
nine eight
all right is this another audio it is
your honor um
and i i will give the um the excerpts
that we propose to play
uh and i'll say uh your honor this is a
it's a lengthy recording where well i
already have 598a in evidence so right
and i just wanted to clarify um spoke
with miss myers this morning we're going
to we're going to speak at a break
it's a
we're trying to be very careful about
whether there's a third party on the
tape this is one where at the very end
um someone else comes in
um but miss myers and i will speak and
we may be to the extent your your honor
is agreeable we may be agreeable to just
entering the whole thing um as evidence
but for now since there's a very small
portion at the end that we're not going
to play of a third party we'll just i'll
just give you the excerpts if that works
then i need 598 b and i need to know
what the time of the excerpts are and
we'll prepare that for you your honor
thank you
well i need it now i mean
i have the okay the excerpts so this
would be
b okay and it's seconds one through 20.
and then it's minutes 30 minutes and two
seconds
through 31 minutes and 45 seconds okay
all right
any objection to
598b then no objection your honor thank
you
[Music]
if not being able to do no i meant
exactly what i said what did you say at
least i'm not doing it behind your back
i'm telling you
he gave me [ __ ] that i was recording and
i said yeah i'm recording but at least
i'm telling you okay and if you would
ask me not to i wouldn't
well record
okay so the next excerpt is minute 30
and 30 minutes and two seconds
but die
walking away
is necessary
is necessary especially between you and
us it is
of utmost importance because the next
move if i don't walk away
or just go out for a little while
just it's just gonna be it's just gonna
be a bloodbath and like you know
like it was on the island of course like
it was you know
it's not this is not worth it
let's just can we just it's the options
for that i have some
some some of us understanding for each
other
please ken
because i'm not trying to say
hey by the way no one in that right mind
is going to choose
a
bloodbath
over walking away obviously if you're
given the option between the two then
why has it been chosen so many times
it's that's no goal it is not a distinct
choice that either one of us may get any
discernible point no it's stubbornness
and it's all you know what it builds
right like you build i build you know it
isn't like at one moment either of us
sign a certificate of saying or like
sign the contract or
say okay now i'll apply that no
so acting as though there's a choice
between the two is relevant
i'm not asking you to stay
over having a bloodbath i'm asking you i
mean over walking away i'm not asking
you to have a bloodbath before walking
away i'm asking you to work it out
over prolonging it to making it bigger
can you please pull up
defense exhibit 161 which was admitted
into evidence on thursday your honor i
believe
okay
yes it was thank you
now that recording that we just heard mr
depp isn't the first time that you
um
refer to
an argument as a bloodbath in fact
in this text exchange that we saw on
friday
when
you informed ms heard that there exists
a book entitled disco bloodbath and she
asks you if it is about last friday
night by any chance you say how can you
make me smile about such a hideous
moment
yes it is funny [ __ ]
i read that right
certainly did sir thank you
can we pull up exhibit 586 please
your honor the only um that the portion
of this exhibit that we would plan to
play it's a recording
is minutes 7 35 to 8 20. okay but i
already have a 586 a so this would be
586 b if
735 to what 820. thank you
no objection to 586b no objection all
right 586b
oh yes you do because you wouldn't have
used that as a way
i would pour my heart out to you what do
you do
let me get it let me get it stabbed in
here
that's what you saw huh you listen to me
cry and you're like
now i can get her
is that what you think
you just do it without thinking
you do without thinking um
get
stabbing when you can you throw a swing
when you can and win better than when
i'm on the floor because that's when
it's really good to hit someone
can you please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 366.
this is another recording your honor
that we would propose to admit all of
although we will only be playing minute
320 through 338.
all right so no objection to 366 in its
entirety is that correct
uh that's correct you're on all right
366 in evidence
he's only playing part
i'll play this i'm sorry
[Music]
you're a flower
[Music]
because you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
can you please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 396.
your honor portions of this were used on
thursday so with your leave we'd like to
introduce this as
b
with the following excerpts
2 44
and 0 seconds
through 2 44 and 16 seconds
and then 249 and 30 seconds
through 249 and 55 seconds
all right any objection to 396b
no objection you're on here 396b
um
please what
this is
[Music]
this is not helping
you could please go to 249 in 30 seconds
please
i don't [ __ ] care you shut up
talk to you later
you heard ms heard say get off me
right
that's your thing no i did not i heard
s
distance screaming and i heard i'll talk
to you later i'll talk to you later
let's look at exhibit 857 please
that's defendants857 yes your honor okay
this is another audio file oh no it's
not no
okay
mr depp i'd like to direct your
attention to the second to last text
yes
on this this is a text from you
to your agent christian carino
on august 15 2016
that's correct that's what it looks like
yes objection your honor relevance and
prejudice
after the divorce
if you can approach
your honor to for the sake of time um
i'll go ahead and
ask the witness about the portions that
we discussed and then we can provide a
redacted version okay
mr depp in this in this text message
from you to christian carino your agent
on august 15 2016
um
you you tell him
you you go on at some some length about
amber but you say
she will hit the wall hard
for exclamation points
and then later down you say i can only
hope that karma kicks in and takes the
gift of breath from her
did i read that right objection compound
you read that correctly
and this wasn't the first time that you
talked about amber hitting the wall hard
let's pull up exhibit 213 please
hitting the wall hard
based on
i'm sorry i was talking is that all
right you you would answer my question
we'll take a look at the next element
thank you
as long as you're happy sir
mr depp this is a text that you sent to
bruce witkin on february 4th 2014
at the top of my interview
on your screen please
i figured that out
the top text on the screen okay i didn't
know if there was a specific if it was
third from the bottom or
somewhere around the corner
what would you like me to do this is a
text that you sent to bruce witkin on
february 4th 2014. correct
2014 yes okay yes you're on our move for
admission of this exhibit with uh just
that text displayed
um with the redactions applied and also
the identifiers okay
we have that ready all right 213
evidence with redactions
[Music]
move for the admission of this
permission to publish your honor there
it is in evidence you can publish it
mr depp on february 4 2014 you tell mr
witkin
amber and i hit the wall hard
you see that
i do and that's the same phrase that you
used in your text to mr carino from 2016
that we just read correct
they are similar words but they have
different meanings yes
exhibit
498 please
mr depp is this a text exchange that you
had with miss heard uh on or about
october 28 2015.
yes sir
and i'd like to
direct your attention to the third text
down
yes
you're on our move for the admission of
defendants exhibit 498 with
identifiers redacted
any objection
uh relevance your honor
all right
maybe approach
can you pull up exhibit 330 please
mr depp i'd like to turn your attention
to the
the middle text on this page which is a
text from you to someone named ryan a
uh on
january 12 2015. do you see that
january
the second one from the last yes
uh january 12th
yes yes sir
is that ryan adams the singer
yes it is
um you're on a move for uh admission of
defendants exhibit 330 um just plan on
asking about that text
uh objection relevance your honor
if we i'm happy to approach if you want
can you pull up exhibit 620 please
mr depp i'd like to uh turn your
attention to
text number 40.
okay it's the third one down
yes this is a text from you to malcolm
connolly
is that right that's correct
your honor i'd move for admission of
this document
with the third text down
if i just sure
i'm happy to approach to discuss if your
honor would like
uh relevance objection again your honor
okay if you want to pray
redacted
mr rottenborn if that's coming in we'd
like like um the contextual text
messages as well if we might take a look
please
i'm sorry
we would like to take a look and just
make sure the contextual text messages
are coming in with the one that you're
directing mr depp to
i'm just going to address the court
that that was the text message that
i would like to get into if they're i'm
not sure what she's asking we'll just
we'll just go forward with that text
message for now okay
mr deb you remember last week the jury
saw the video of you
[Music]
as you called it assaulting the
cupboards in that kitchen on sweets or
avenue
yes you're very well said and that was
on or about february 10th to 2016.
correct objection calls for speculation
out loud if you can i have i've i'm not
i don't know when that's from i have
asked for the metadata i've asked for
the date and receive nothing okay
um
this text you sent on february 10 2016
to
uh to malcolm connolly
malcolm conley is one of your security
guards correct yes yes and in this text
you say
thanks dear mal
i'm just at the point where i feel like
i'm going to puke all the time
once i get this [ __ ] moving and get
myself out of her level of [ __ ]
i will never mention
this cunt's name again
ever again
and the first prick that asks about her
gets a warning
should the single cell prick decide to
push it
he never forgets me and will always be
remembered throughout his life as the
guy that got his [ __ ] nose bit off
chewed up and swallowed by johnny depp
while i do have some civilized bones in
my body just on a matter of principle i
must force him to watch me fulfill this
promise of mangling his [ __ ] of
abeezer love you x
did i read that right
you did
i'd like to turn to your views on miss
herd's career can you please pull up
exhibit 195.
i'd like to direct your attention to the
second to last text from the bottom
this is a text message exchange between
you and miss heard on october 29 2013
correct
it looks like
you're on our move for the admission of
defendants exhibit 195 with the
appropriate identifiers redacted
uh we would object on relevance grounds
your honor
your honor this is him expressing his
views on her taking a meeting
about a movie
her career his views
so 195 will be in evidence with
redacted with the identifiers
mr deb you see the the text that
from from amber that says i'm at a
coffee meeting now you see that
i do start there so she tells you at uh
at 12 41 pm i'm at a coffee meeting now
we'll be home soon
and then you respond
holy crap [ __ ]
no god damn meetings
no movies
why
why do you deviate from our agreement
what species of meeting
[ __ ] it just tell me when you get home
i read that right
you did but a coffee meeting
you didn't want her to take the meeting
that she was taking that day correct
um it seems as though we had an
agreement uh
what seems like
we had an agreement to do something
together i'm actually asking asking what
species of
mating so
this is
not necessarily uh
an
angry
text it's just
why do you deviate from our agreement
it's not about her doing
films
how do you think she got aquaman sir you
tell her no goddamn meetings no movies
because you didn't want her acting you
wanted to control her career correct
objection compound
all right yes i'll sustain the objection
next question
sorry let's
we can we can move on uh exhibit 394
please
defendants exhibit
mr depp if you can take a look at the
the fourth text down this is a text from
you
to
dr kipper
on
um
it's in the the time stamp issue i
believe it was sent on march 8 2015 in
australia time stamped march 7th 2015.
do you see that i do
you're on our move for the admission of
394.
no objection with the proper redactions
of the rest of the text messages and the
identifiers okay
thank you your honor 394 evidence with
redactions
so
permission to publish
all right yes yes sir
mr depp on this date uh
right after you had
suffered an injury to your finger you
text dr kipper and you say hi
[ __ ] man had another one i just cannot
live like this
she is as full of [ __ ] as a christmas
goose i'm done
no more
the constant insults the demeaning
belittling most heartbreaking spew that
is only released from a malicious evil
and vindictive [ __ ]
but you know what far more hurtful than
her venomous and degrading endless
educational ranting is her hideously and
purposely hurtful tirades and her
goddamn shocking treatment of the man
she was meant to love above all
here's the real deal mate
her obsession with herself is far more
important
she is so [ __ ] ambitious
she's so desperate for success and fame
that's probably why i was acquired mate
although she has hammered me with what a
sad old man has been i am
cowan has done me the most cruel of
favors i'm so very sad
i cut the top of my middle finger off
what should i do except of course go to
a hospital i'm so embarrassed for
jumping into anything with her [ __ ] the
world
do i read that right
yes mr rottenborn
so even as you are
ranting about miss her to dr kipper even
as you were talking about her ambition
and expressing your objections to that
you
still admit to him that you cut the top
of your middle finger off correct
objection compound all right sustain his
compound
you're complaining about her ambition in
this text to her
to dr kipper correct
um i'm realizing that her ambition is
far stronger than her
supposed feelings for me yes
and there's nothing about this text
that's trying to protect her
protector
and from what and you tell dr kipper i
cut the top of my middle finger off in
this text correct
it's just the way it was worded
it doesn't mean that
i actually literally cut my finger off
after
at the age of 12 finding the only thing
that gave me
a piece
which is playing the guitar
very unlikely why didn't i start lopping
off digits when i was uh 13 just the way
it was worded now mr miss heard wasn't
the only one who had a problem with you
you can take that down misheard wasn't
the only one who had a problem with your
drinking
and abuse of alcohol correct objection
compound
all right i'll sustain the objection if
you misheard wasn't the only one who had
a problem with your drinking
correct
sort if anyone had a problem with my
drinking at any time in my life it was
me the only person that i have ever
abused in my life is myself in fact you
tried to hide your drinking from your
daughter lily rose didn't you
objection relevance what's the relevance
when you're nervous
can you pull up exhibit 207 please
you scroll down please
thank you mr depp i'd like to direct
your attention to the last text on this
page
it's a text from you
to
um
kevin murphy
he was your
your estate manager correct
he was
this is a text from you to kevin murphy
on january 21st 2014
correct
yes sir
your honor i'd move for the admission of
that portion of defendants exhibit 207
with redactions
with the uh identifiers redacted that's
fine thank you
permission to publish
yes sir
and in this text to kevin murphy on
february or sorry january 21st 2014
you say
just trying to get over my shocking
discussion with vanessa that lasted five
plus hours vanessa's your former partner
correct
she's the mother of my children yes the
mother of your children that's right and
then you say i feel ill and have
invested my guts into some side corner
now
lily rose hates me
because she thinks i'm drinking
and she's right
but i can't admit or i [ __ ] die in
her eyes
thanks for that one vanessa
come to master in maine house
did i read that correctly you do
can you pull up exhibit 1092 please
[Music]
mr depp is this a picture of you
passed out in a chair
during daylight hours
again isn't passed out
[Music]
that's a very specific term sleep
could be one
passed out
um
let's just let let's try it this way
this is a picture of you in a chair
correct
that is correct move for the admission
of 1092 your honor
any objection
i'm i'm
relevant to your honor
your honor i'm trying to move this along
and when we stop with relevance
you want to lay a foundation i just
don't
this is a picture of mr depp
as we've introduced another
on thursday another picture of that
what is the date of this photograph i'm
sorry
can you take that down and put
put up exhibit 470 michelle please
mr depp is this is the bottom text on
this page a text exchange or a text
message from you to your personal
assistant stephen deuters
on september 3rd 2015.
that's what it looks like yesterday
your honor i'd move for the admission of
this exhibit
with just that text and the appropriate
redactions
except at 470.
yeah again a relevance your honor
and cumulative i'll allow this one if we
thank you
with redactions
wow
permission to publish your honor
all right
thank you
mr deb
in the effort to to move this along i'm
not going to read the whole thing
um but i'm going to start with the the
word main bits which is five lines down
you write to mr deuters on september 3rd
2015 main bits needed are xanax and
adderall
and
i want no judgment from kipper or debbie
kipper means dr david kipper correct
that's correct and debbie means debbie
lloyd your sobriety nurse correct that
is correct
just found out from joel last night how
much i spent on having kipper and debbie
around
millions and [ __ ] millions mate
all the while debbie just hung around
broad
bch and gave me new meds like every two
weeks
she was on set maybe four times
wow and five money symbols sorry just
how it is did i read that right you did
can we pull up exhibit 587 please this
is a recording your honor
and i already have 5787a so this is 587
587 b you're on our feet
um the excerpts to be played are 1940
through 1953
and 2304 through 23.29
any objection
no objection your honor
5817 evidence
[Music]
i know
[Music]
in that clip mr deputy tell ms heard i'm
never getting clean and sober correct
it sounds like to me uh
that
yes either that or i have never been
clean and sober thank you let's play
2304 please
in the big picture the big schema thinks
it does nothing but hurt us and why
because of cold boost doesn't make it
easier for you to see how clearly that
is
you got to stop with the coconut oil all
the coke all the coke you've done today
and all the booze you've drank today by
the way has it helped you
has it helped us just got the coke has
it helped us it's our day yeah i know
because la yesterday you are a thousand
times better
yesterday
i'd like to turn now to a few more of
your words around the time that you went
into detox about how you viewed amber's
role in that process mr deb
can you please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit
120
underscore 40.
in your honor
120 underscore 41 was admitted the other
the other day but um
i'd like to introduce this as a separate
exhibit so 120 b
and that would be underscore 40 you said
4-0 yes your
honor any objection to that
um
if i may
just come up okay
mr deb while they're looking at that is
the
second text from the bottom a text that
you sent to amber's mom page
on august 19 2014
yes that's correct and this is when you
were
either in the middle of or finishing up
your detox process from oxycodone
correct that is correct
all right and no no objection no exactly
okay 120b in evidence
you want to publish oh you did um as is
correct uh with with the other
okay text messages redacted all right
thank you
oh with you okay sure
okay publish
and in this text message
that you write amber's mom
on august 19 2014
you say my dearest page how unbelievably
kind and pure your message was
i am beyond thankful to have you in my
life
there is no luckier man on this earth
to have the strength that amber gives me
and the full support of each of you
individually that i've gotten helps
immeasurably
i don't need to explain the horrors to
you you know as well as i
what you do need to know
that your daughter has risen far above
the nightmarish task of taking care of
this poor old junkie
never a second has gone by that she
didn't look out for me
or have her eyes on me to make sure that
i was okay
yn words are truly feeble in attempting
to explain her heroism in a text suffice
to say that i have never met or loved a
woman or a thing more
she has the strength of a thousand men
and that is due
to no one or nothing but you sweetheart
thank you i love you
your son outlaw
did i read that correctly
you did
i'd like to take a look at another
document um
exhibit 272 please
is this a text message
that you shared a text message exchange
between you and amber
the following day on april 20th 2014.
yes sir
you're on a permission to uh move for
the
admission of exhibit 272 and ask for
permission to publish uh with the
identifiers removed we have no objection
all right
all right 272 in evidence ezra jack
now mr depp you testified on thursday
that you saw nothing wrong with
referring to amber as a lesbian camp
counselor when she was trying to get you
to stop using drugs but she let's take a
look at what you say she has used that
term before in this text mr depp you say
just to let you know that i'm fine my
angel
i miss you of course
but this was the right thing to do to
speed up the process i love you more
than life
yours steve did i read that correctly
you did
you can take that down
now you've brought this lawsuit about
the op-ed specifically but for years
prior to the date that ms heard wrote
the op-ed there were numerous negative
news stories about you you'd agree with
that correct objection compound
a sustainable compound for years prior
to 2018 when amber wrote the op-ed there
were numerous negative news stories
about you that were released into the
public correct objection calls for
speculation
aloud if you can answer
um by 2018 you're saying correct
yes it all started with um miss hurt
going to
going directly to a court to get a tro
which is
with a bruise on her face and paparazzi
uh that that was the sort of beginning
of the
the ball
rolling down the hill and gaining
momentum there were lots of negative
stories about you prior to may 27 2016
when amber went into court correct
objection asked and answered
now it's 2016. i'll allow it
there were plenty of negative stories
about you
prior to that date weren't there
so i've
i've been in this
the racket of hollywood since 1984.
um
my
mr deputy that's
i'm asking you a yes or no question
there were plenty of negative news
stories about you prior to may 27 2016.
correct
from 1984 up until then they're all
they're both
so
of course people write negative stories
sure and you just testified to the jury
that it all started on may 27 2016. so
that's why i asked you to clarify about
the negative stories prior to that date
and you'd agree that there were correct
can you be specific about the stories of
course there's negative stories
permission to approach your honor all
right
your honor i have here um
numerous exhibits in one sort of
compendium
all
press articles about mr death if i may
approach
all right
thank you so much
your honor in in
having received this i i would like to
preemptively logic hearsay lack of
foundation and he hasn't got him in
evidence yet are you moving no i'm happy
to i'm happy to approach but they're
certainly not being admitted for the
truth of the matter assertive but i'm
happy to
all
approach
mr depp if you could please take a look
at the the stack of articles in front of
you
um
yes it's a stack of hit pieces
the first one
we're going to try to get through this
as quickly as possible um i'm going to
ask you about the first one well we're
going to we're going to talk about them
the first one is entitled uh it's from
the guardian do you see that it's
apparently drunk yes and this is an
article from from november 15 2014
entitled apparently drunk johnny depp
cut off at hollywood film awards
ceremony correct
that's what it says yesterday the next
article
is an article from
may 7 2016.
it's entitled johnny depp
friends and family seriously concerned
about him here's why
yes how did they know
the next article
from may 1st 2017 before miss heard
filed uh for a restraining order
a year and a half before she published
um no sorry this would be this would be
after may 1st 2017.
the headline is johnny depp has a clear
and epic sense of entitlement
ex-managers say yes in the hollywood
reporter correct i was in a lawsuit with
them so
the next article from may 10 2017
is entitled johnny depp a star in crisis
and the insane story of his missing
millions did i read that right that's
straight from the same lawsuit
the next article also from may 10 2017
a year and a half before the op-ed was
published
says johnny depp reportedly drank
heavily and was constantly late on the
new pirates movie set did i read that
right you did reportedly the next
article
also remains in 2017
mr depp please just respond to the
question that i'm asking you
the next question the next the next
document
an article published in vanity fair
on may 10 2017 yes is entitled johnny
depp's financial woes might sink the
next pirates of the caribbean did i read
that right
you you did i don't know the next
article
may 25th 2017 a year and a half before
the op-ed was published an article
entitled where did it all go wrong for
johnny depp
after a string of flops and a ton of bad
press johnny depp's star power looks as
wobbly as jack sparrow on a plank did i
read that right you read that very very
well the next one hollywood reporter may
27 2017
headline pirates of the caribbean the
diminishing returns of johnny depp did i
read that right
you certainly did hollywood reporter
were very nice to me july 12 2017
why are all of johnny depp's movies
bombing at the box office did i read
that right
um
you certainly did
november 4th 2017
a year and a month before
amber published the op-ed headline
johnny depp allegedly showed up drunk to
movie premiere reports say i read that
correctly
this is huge june 21st 2018
six months before the op-ed was
published
vanity fair article the real reason
johnny depp used an earpiece on a film
set
i think that was extremely cool
june 21st 2018
six months before the op-ed was
published a rolling stone article
entitled the trouble with johnny depp
multi-million dollar lawsuits a haze of
booze and hash a marriage gone very
wrong and a lifestyle he can't afford
inside the trials of johnny depp did i
read that right you did you should read
the article and the last one the last
one
june 22nd 2018
the daily mail vodka for breakfast
72-hour drug binges and spending sprees
that beggar belief
alison beauchaff reveals why hollywood's
reeling over what's being called johnny
depp's career suicide note did i read
that correctly you did who's alison
beauchelf and how does she know
mr depp you can't name a single
actress
who has benefited in her career by
coming forward and stating that she was
the victim of domestic violence can you
i'm sorry objection calls for
speculation i'll sustain the objection
next question
when amber made abuse accusations
against you in may 2016
fair to say got a lot of press attention
right
objection calls for speculation
all right i'll sustain the objection
next question when amber made abuse
accusations against you in may 2016 you
became aware that it got a lot of press
attention correct
very quickly
i became aware and she became associated
with those abuse
accusations that she made against you in
may 2016 correct to your knowledge
objection calls for speculation sustain
the objection next question
you you became associated with those
domestic abuse accusations that she made
against you correct
i think that's clear and you understood
that she and you understood that she
became associated with those same
accusations that she made correct you
testified to that
well
she had a choice i didn't and you've
talked about the immediate impact
that those accusations on may 27 2016
allegedly had on your career correct
yes you testified earlier in your
examination on direct that when amber
made those accusations in 2016 you said
you lost quote nothing less than
everything correct
that was correct
but you didn't try to get the
restraining order lifted in 2016 did you
i
i don't
if she wanted a restraining yes or no
question you didn't try to get the
restroom
and you didn't have a divorce trial
where you could respond to amber's
accusations of abuse in 2016 did you
objection calls for a legal conclusion
i'm asking him if he had a trial that's
a fact you didn't have a divorce trial
where you could respond to amber's
accusations of abuse did you
no there were no
charges pressed against you you chose
not to tell the police that i had done
anything she didn't mention my name and
and you didn't you didn't have a
california divorce judge decide these
facts did you
objection
you chose objection you chose not to try
to clear your name at that time
through any sort of legal proceeding
correct objection asked and answered
i'll sustain the objection and you chose
to sign a divorce agreement in which you
stated that amber had not made any false
statements about you for financial gain
we looked at that correct objection
asked an answer asked and answered all
sustaining objection next question in
fact you waited until amber wrote the
op-ed in the washington post in december
of 2018 to file a lawsuit against her
correct
that is correct can you pull out
plaintiff's exhibit 2 please it was the
only time that i was able to speak and
use my own voice
you chose not to sue the washington post
in this lawsuit correct
objection relevance
asked and answered it's not been asked
and answered
hasn't been asked to answer but i'm not
sure what the relevance is
you chose to sue only miss heard and not
the newspaper that published this
article correct objection compound all
right i'll sustain us to compound you
chose not to sue the washington post
correct objection relevance i'll sustain
objection
you only sued the author
of this article amber heard correct
which seems she was the one making the
statements yes i
had the opportunity to
fight back
permission to publish exhibit two your
honor all right two is already in
evidence
mr deb you realize that the only job for
this jury to decide yes sir its only job
is to determine whether this
op-ed
and this op-ed alone is defamatory
objection calls for a legal conclusion
i'll sustain the objection
this is the only
writing
that you are that's the subject of this
lawsuit that you brought correct same
objections fact your honor
i love that question
this
is a version of that story of the op-ed
that i have never seen the one that was
published before the one that
the only one i've ever seen is the one
that was published
prior to this they changed the title
because they were in fear of
trouble
well i moved to strike that last
testimony
whether it's the online edition or this
edition in the paper
this
article is the only statement the only
publication of anything that's the
subject of the lawsuit that you brought
correct objection asked and answered
sustain the objection
this op-ed mr depp does not discuss any
of the details of your relationship that
we've seen in texts and emails and
recordings over the past few days does
it objection compound and asked and
answered now sustain both objections
in fact this article doesn't contain
any details of your relationship with mr
objection asked and answered
the only thing that this article states
mr depp is that in 2016 amber made
accusations of domestic abuse
correct
i
it was clear that she made allegations
in 2016. and she did that when she
obtained a restraining order against you
in 2016. correct
um
yeah
yes and even if you disagree
with the accusations that she made
against you in may 2016 it is a true
fact that she did make those accusations
in 2016 and got a restraining order
against you correct objection compound
asked and answered sustained objections
next question
to your knowledge
the words
that misheard used in this article
about getting a restraining order
against you in 2016
those are true correct
i'm sorry the words the mystery document
all right i'll sustain the objection
can you can you go to um
the third paragraph look the third
paragraph please
the statement that
then two years ago
miss heard became a public figure
representing domestic abuse
that is true isn't it
i'm not sure what we're looking at
oh i see
calls for a legal conclusion i'll
sustain the objection
i'll sustain the objection
and in 2016
for the first time publicly
miss heard accused you of domestic abuse
correct
in 2016 yes
that's correct
no further questions all right ladies
and gentlemen let me go ahead and take
our morning recess for 15 minutes do not
do any outside research and do not talk
to anybody about the case okay we'll
come back in 15 minutes
ready for the jury
do
um
um
all right be seated and redirect
good afternoon mr deb
hi
[Music]
could we please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit one
mr depp is this the version of the op-ed
that you recognize
yes ma'am that's the one
um
i would move exhibit one plaintiff's
exhibit one into evidence and ask that
it be published to the jury any
objection all right one in evidence and
publish
mr depp when did you see miss herd's
december 18 2018 op-ed for the first
time
it was um
it was uh
presented to me by
one of my team i can't remember but um
it was
within a day or so of it
a couple of days having been written i i
believe
and what was your reaction when you saw
it
shock
why were you shocked
because i
[Music]
at that point it had been a good solid
two or two or so years
of this um
of the accusations of the allegations
um
planted firmly on my back so something
that i had to carry with me
um
and
i just couldn't believe that
that it was continuing
um
oh that it was continuing in such a way
that the the
it was clear that the more bad press the
more hit pieces that came out on me the
more of these
stories of mr heard
um and her
righteous
um
chase
um
against me
the the it
it was
it wasn't stopping
and and um
it's difficult to um
[Music]
once you've chewed on it for a couple of
years it's
becomes pretty difficult to swallow
anymore
as it's
as it was completely untrue
how did you feel when you saw the op-ed
for the first time
objection asked and answered just now
i my prior question was about his
reaction all right i'll allow it
hurts
yeah a blinding um
a blinding
hurt it was it was like somebody hit me
in the back of the head with a two by
four i um
and
as it said i had no
had no ability to speak prior to
because
even if i had done an interview to try
to explain myself
it turned into a hit piece
so
my mouth was uh
shut
um and this was the opportunity where i
thought
it
something's got to be done
it's just got to be done
i couldn't take it anymore
when did you first learn that disney was
not going to recast you in the pirates
franchise
it was
a probably two or three days after
this op-ed appeared
um
one of my crew again i don't remember
who had sent me
excuse me
had sent me um
a piece that was in some
magazine and
sean bailey who was the
the number three objection hearsay
i i don't know yet i'll rule it at this
point thank you
may i continue your honor yes sir thank
you
um
sean bailey who was the
the third
the third in line as i suppose in the
upper echelon of disney
um
just basically said in the injection
hearsay
this is about him learning about this
it's not for the truth
it is the truth she's actually
approached
[Music]
mr depp could you please explain to the
jury who sean bailey is
i think you we're starting to yes i'll
try again
um sean bailey is
the
number three or was at the time i don't
know what his status is anymore but uh
at the time he was the number three
sort of upper echelon of disney top dogs
and uh
sean bailey was quoted
as as
saying that objection hearsay
mr deb where was john bailey quoted
without getting into what he was quoted
as saying
he was quoted in
whatever the article
was that i was uh that was brought to my
attention
and can you please just clarify what
article you're referring to
i don't know what
what the journal it came from i don't
know what magazine i don't
know
any
of that so i don't know i don't know who
did the interview with him objection
lack of foundation
a rule objection go ahead
mr depp how did you feel when you
learned that
you were being dropped from the pirates
of the caribbean franchise
um
well it was
the pirates of the caribbean franchise
um
it was
the character that
captain jack sparrow was a character
that i had
built from the ground up
um
and
with something that i
i
i
of course put a lot of
my as you do with all characters but you
put a lot of yourself
into the characters so
and
also
having
worked on
these films with these people and
having added
much of myself much of my own
rewriting of the dialogue and
scenes and the jokes and whatever they
are
i didn't quite understand
how
that after that long relationship and
quite a successful
relationship certainly for disney
um that
they would
but that suddenly i was
guilty until proven innocent
up until the point that you learned that
you were
not going to be in the pirates of the
caribbean franchise any longer what was
your intention with respect to future
pirates movies
the
the last thing that i knew
from
the
um
the
i said that the
there's the producer team there's the
creative team
um
[Music]
and there were many discussions
um
i in fact
had been approached to
take part in writing
mr depp what was your intention with
respect to future pirates movies
aside from what you'd been asked to do
my feeling was that
these characters
should be able to
have their proper
goodbye
as it were
a franchise can only last for so long
um
and
um
there's a way to end
a franchise like that and i thought that
the characters
deserve to
to have their
their way out of
to
to end the
franchise on a
on a on a very good note i planned on
continuing i
until it was time to stop
mr deb um last week mr rottenborn asked
you about a quote where you said you
wouldn't come back to the pirates
franchise for 300 million dollars and a
million alpacas do you remember that
i do
when relative to learning that you would
no longer be a part of the pirates
franchise did you make that statement
i think long before i
made the statement
there was
a very
deep and distinct sense of having been
betrayed
by
the people that i had
been working with the people that i had
worked hard for
the people that i had delivered a
character to
that they initially despised but somehow
um
you know even i stuck to my guns with
the character and it seemed to work
so
um
do you recall when specifically you made
that statement about the 300 million
dollars and the 100 alpacas objection
asked an answer
overruled i'll allow it
um
i believe i made that statement during a
press conference in the san sebastian
film at the san sebastian film festival
when i was
i was asked about
my um
well situation
and what year would that have been if
you can recall i believe it was last
year or so
can we please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 804
mr duff do you recognize this document
as soon as my eyes go on i hopefully
will
um
scatter manga brothers yes pirates four
and five yes
what is this document
[Music]
i
don't quite know i'd have to read it to
get some
understanding of it
could we scroll through so mr depp can
look at the rest of this document
oops
oh there it goes
it looks uh this appears to me to be
some
species of contract
is this a contract that you entered into
with disney
your honor i'd ask that
uh plaintiff's exhibit
804 be moved into evidence and published
any objection
i think it's outside the scope of direct
or cross-examination
i'll rule on that objection okay and
yeah
i'll reserve other objections to
portions of the document um
depending on what she's going to ask
about it could be hearsay
but she's asking me to put it all into
evidence right now well then i i would
object to that at this point are you
going to come forward
copy that at some point okay thank you
uh mr depp if i could direct your
attention to section six of the contract
which is on pages 8 through 10 of the
document
mr deb what does this reflect
um
sorry
it appears to be the agreement
um
of
pirates four and
five
incumbent compensation and
merchandise
mr deb at this time how many other
franchise films had you been a part of
um at that time alice alice in
wonderland
um
oh boy
um alison wonderland
um
i'm so
pathetic when it comes to knowing what
movies i've done i'm sorry i i just
i don't
watch them
i
feel better not watching them um
i couldn't like
i mean
what was the question again uh how many
water in
thank you
how many other franchise films have you
been a part of at the time of this
contract
um there was a third there was there was
pirates
there was um
oh
sorry um
with warner brothers uh
fantastic beasts and where to find them
and then crimes of grindelwald
and how does the compensation reflected
in this contract compared to that
what you receive for the other
franchises that you've been a part of
objection foundation
he he just established that he was a
member of other franchise
films at this point and
he hasn't established a foundation that
he knows how he was compensated for
all of rule of direction if you can
answer
um
i believe
um
the compensation obviously all the
pay and
back end and all those things are
negotiated by
agents lawyers and this was
comparatively this this was
this is my salary on that film
um
and other other salaries were of a
similar
of a similar
status i
suppose if i could direct your attention
to the 12th page of the document
yes
cool
is this your signature mr depp
yes it is okay we can take this down
thank you
mr deb i i recall that you testified
that you don't know
during a given period what movies you
were working on so my question is who
would know that
um
well first and foremost my agent
or agents um
i do recall a couple of the other films
that i made after
one was um
initially called richard says goodbye
and that was uh
they changed the name to the professor
and uh
during all of the
um
nastiness over the past
six years
that film went straight to
pay-per-view
there was
um
another film
called minimada that was produced uh
uh it was
my my company uh infinitum
nile
we had uh developed a film called
minamata about eugene smith
and uh the minamata
uh
uh
the well the the the the boys mercury
poisoning of of a very small fishing
village in
southern japan
um
there was that one and then there was a
film
called
um waiting for the barbarians with uh
one
mark rylance um and robert pattins and
um
those were three films that i'd
done
mr depp during your cross-examination mr
rottenborn showed you a number of text
messages between you and and paul
bettany do you remember that i do
um could you explain please explain to
the jury what your relationship with mr
bettany is
mr bedne and i had
we'd met
while i was making a film called the
tourist in in venice
and we were um
it was an instant connection he's he's
uh
born and bred in the uk and uh has a
that
english uh
sort of dry
kind of obtuse abstract sense of humor
um and that was one of the things that
we connected on this
uh
even if it was a difficult uh or un
unpleasant situation we would
you know do our best to deal with it
with humor as opposed to
just
a constant complaint or whining or
anything of that nature we dealt with it
with humor
albeit sometimes um
in
as these are private texts that uh have
been
there there was a lot of um
if in context
it's important to know that
none of it was ever
intended to be real
and the language that's used
which i
yes i am ashamed that um that has to be
spread on the uh
on the world like um
peanut butter
i uh
for example the text
that is about
um
burning
ms heard is
it's it's it's it's directly from monty
python
um in the sketch about burning witches
um
and then drowning the witches this is a
this is a film that
we'd all watched when we were
10 and
it's it's just um
irreverent and
abstract humor
um that's what we were referring to in
those texts
the the text message that you just
referenced other than mr betany who else
saw that text message
at the time that it was sent
no one
of course not
based on your own observations how would
you describe mr betney's relationship
with miss heard while you and miss heard
were together
abominable
why was that
um
ms heard despised
mr putney
because
mainly because we had become such close
friends
and for her he was a threat
um and would
take me away from her
in with regard to
if paul bentley was getting the
attention from me
that that was a
that was uh
that was a showstopper it would it would
cause
all kinds of um
unpleasantries
to the point of where
when we were on the island
with mr betany
his wife and his uh
four children
um
ms hurd and mr bettany
got into
some debate
over lunch
and
i just remember
that
whenever mr benny tried to make a point
she would talk over him and then it
started to get quite rude
she got
she got mean
um
and she got loud
and then his
i believe it was his
18 year old boy
who was
he was he was getting ready to go to a
really he's a very bright bright
brilliant
kid
he entered the uh conversation
because this was something to do with
what he'd studied in school and he knew
quite a lot about it and he voiced his
opinion
and
uh
miser demeaned that young man
to the point of where he where he
he burst into
tears
and
walked away
and it was at that point
that
i had
spoken and misheard and said that's
that's just unacceptable that behavior
is unacceptable
you have no right
to to to demean that boy to
you cannot
always be right you should try being
wrong sometime because you might learn
something
and then um
i asked her
i asked her to
i thought it was best that she leave
the island
could we please pull up defendants
exhibit 245.
and mr depp i believe this is another
text message with mr betney that you
were shown on your cross examination
and directing your attention to the text
message at the top of the page from may
30th 2014
do you recognize this text message you
sent to paul bettany
yes i do
and
could you please describe to the jury
what you are conveying to mr benny in
this message
this again is it's a this is a
i suppose an example of
the way that i write
um
and
express myself
that is to say
you stretch
you stretch the
um you stretch your situation
out to
to give him the understanding that
you're drowning
essentially
so
everything that i say here is
in fact
an impossibility
for the human body i i i would have been
well i would have certainly at least
had to be rushed to the hospital for a
stomach pump um
there's a line here
that if if you don't mind i say that
when i say i'm done
i'm
admittedly too
[ __ ] pardon me [ __ ] in the head
to spray my rage at the one i love
for little reason as well i'm too old to
be that guy but pills are fine
the pills that were referenced were
were the pills that i had had to that i
was
coming off of and
um
they were the only thing that could
give me
some semblance of
the same
numb
numbing effect that i searched for
as a child with
with my mother
and
saying that i was too messed up in the
head
was
it it's kind of like if you've been told
since you were a child that everything
you do is wrong
um
and that
the
i shouldn't have even been alive or
whatever
you know joyous little treats that my
my then very sick very ill mother
um
brought to me
[Music]
missouri was well aware of my past my
childhood
therefore
was
very adept at
knowing exactly
which buttons to push
so
at this point i mean i i felt like
well i was that little boy again in my
head like
i guess i'm i guess i'm the
i guess i am
incapable of doing anything right i
guess i will never be
happy i guess that
this is
who who i am
i can't get along with this person what
but but it was
it's confusion you know it's um
it's it's nothing that you can
it's nothing that anyone could sustain
for any length of time it's it's nothing
that anyone should have to
sustain for any length of time when
you're being
demeaned berated
judged
um
[Music]
and and and and treated like a lesser
and treat it as if uh
i'm only surrounded by yes men and i'm a
bad father and that
it was
these
things were endless they they
were endless and they
there was there were there was no call
for them
it's hard to understand why someone that
is supposed to love you
um
could be that cruel
and i i
there's also times where you just say
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna try to
not have a
i won't fall for the argument i won't
participate in the argument
um
because i knew where it would go into
her
circular
pattern of
[Music]
psychological
abuse
mr deb
what do you mean when you use the term
blackout in this text message
um blackout
ah
yes because i'm
i'm talking about
a thousand red bulls and vodkas
a thousand of them
two bottles of champagne
um
no food or days half a bottle of whiskey
um
those things
had that been
all
absolutely true
would have not only caused the blackout
but it would have caused
a severe
[Music]
alcohol poisoning
overdose
i would have had to have gone
immediately
if that were true out of
i would have had to have been taken to a
hospital or i'd just die
um
so
you know
blackout is when someone
gets so uh
drunk
on alcohol essentially on
on alcohol
um
but the the pills that i was that i had
my addiction
that i was addicted to the the roxy
codon which are very very powerful
opiates
um
i
to two of those
would knock me
out
that is to say
so there's blackout which is you can be
a person could be wide awake
and wreaking havoc or having a
giggle
in a blackout and never remember it but
when you go
when you
are
when you've taken the
the prescription medication the
it it it knocks you out you
are certainly not
well
you're not in any condition
to
first of all swing at anyone
you are out you you
you go on what's called the nod
and then it takes you away into sleep
it's just very deep sleep
and
i found that much more
accepting than
having to hear
constant
badgering
and insults
mr depp i'd like to show you defendants
exhibit 153 which um i believe mr
rottenborn also showed you last week yes
do you remember seeing this during
mr rottenburn's examination of these
last week
yeah yes i do okay now i i'd like to
show you the the full text exchange
which is in plaintiff's exhibit 120
and since there's been a number of
uh text messages drawn from this
document this would be plaintus exhibit
120c
which page would that be your underscore
uh this would be four and
five your honor four and five thank you
mr depp do you recognize these text
messages yes i do
your honor i'd move um plaintiff's 120 c
into evidence and ask that to be
published to the jury
all right 120 c in evidence publish
mr deb who are you communicating with in
these text messages
in fact though it says mourinho
i was
these are texts between my
um
ex let's say the vanessa
parody the mother of my children
and
this is a
again
abstract humor
um that we're that we're conveying back
and forth to one another
uh
this was all um
it was a joke it wasn't about it
certainly wasn't about miss heard we
didn't speak it very much
together
do you recall what you were talking
about
i don't recall um
who it was
um
i i don't recall who it was but it was
it was someone who had
um
for some reason
i think it was
oh
i think
the possibility is
that 2013
it might have been we had a
nanny
at one point
um who we in fact
we had uh
we found her
she was caught stealing
even from even from my um
at the time my
uh
yeah maybe 10 11 year old boy
jack
who
was bright enough
because he knew it he was bright enough
he had a
he had a five dollar bill that he wadded
up
and put on his desk in his bedroom
and when he came home from school i'm
just gonna object on relevance
the question was who was this about yeah
we we can move on okay
uh mr depp i'd also like to show you
defendants exhibit 143 which i believe
mr roddenborn also showed you last week
um do you remember seeing this email
exchange
you could scroll down as well please
thank you
oh yes yes yes
um
who are you exchanging these emails with
stephen duders who was at the time was
my assistant
and
what are you and mr duders
discussing here
um
gobbledygook essentially it was
it was a
as i remember it was a day of
work and
um
there were times when i would send a
text to
mr deuters
because he's the worrisome type
i would send him a text
in jest of course
and and uh
to
to get a rise out of him to get some
reaction out of him
so um
you know i would tell him things like
you know i woke up and um i'm bleeding
profusely from from the inside of my ear
is that normal
you know it would be things like that so
this is
exactly the same kind of thing i think
we're even referencing uh
the hangover
uh the film the hangover
uh
in in part of this about the
mike tyson and
um
sort of
bizarre
uh circus that i was telling him that i
had in in my room and that there was
blood everywhere it was it was a joke to
just sort of
throw him off worry him and make
ultimately it was a joke and we we were
laughing about it
mr deb what if any portion of this email
exchange is literally true
we're all set to leave here at
approximately 1 30 p.m hope you rested
well
mr deb i'd like to talk to you about
some text messages that mr rottenborn
showed you where you refer to
the monster and this is in the context
of in conversations with that don't
include misheard do you remember seeing
some of those communications yes okay
first i'd like to show you defendants
exhibit 427 please which is a text
message from youtube jerry judge
how are you using the term monster in
this context when you're communicating
with mr judge
the monster
the monster could essentially
the monster could
it
it could be
two
separate things
the monster in her eyes was
my
um
objection as to what the monster was in
this herd size your honor
all right yes this dance to her eyes if
you wanna okay yes refreeze
the monster was defined
um
by ms heard
as
this
out of control
in your honor what miss herd's view of
the monster was it's not for this
witness to say mr dub how do you know
how misheard defined the word monster
um she said the words to me
okay and how what words did she say
with respect to the term monster
it was
it was her go-to phrase
and
it was the go-to phrase for me being
again
you know
as has been
embellished and elaborated
um
the drug use or the drink or the
whatever but the monster was for me
and again you start to
think about these things
and you put it in your own
head and
what the real context is the monster was
sobriety
the monster was
was
trying to be
to to be sober
because i was
plagued by
these
requests to to stop drinking
but the monster could also be
if a
if
if a conversation
if something starts as a conversation
which would quickly ramp up to
um
quite an antagonizing argument
um
if i
responded
to her
if i took part in the verbal
back and forth where people do
in life end up
saying obscenities screaming obscenities
at one another or or calling them names
or
or
when it gets to that point
um i mean
the monster was just
for me was just
the guy who actually
was dumb enough
to
to to continue to take part in
arguments
that would ultimately get nowhere
um
so that that is
one of the reasons why
i would try to get away
from misheard and not
participate
in her
debates and her
the knowledge that she wanted to express
to me and
circular
and painful
insults that were
constant it was rapid fire
so
i stopped participating in those i tried
to walk away
i tried to go to another room
even to the point of locking myself in
rooms so that she just could
pound on the door and scream
um
that that that
that was clearly i should have never
fallen for that or taken the bait to to
allow myself
to get into
a conversation which led to an argument
which led to physical violence
it it
it was not going to be good so i would
uh
i
would just walk away which drove
through the roof
so mr deb why would you use the term
monster when just when communicating
with people other than misheard
well
because i heard it all the time
i mean it was
as i said that was that was her go-to
the monster the monsters here the
monsters back monster
so i would refer to the monster again
in terms of
some with with uh
elton
or with
friends patty smith
the monster
was uh
like without anything it was just a
monster
was
i i you know
i let the monster creep back in or
something that is sobriety that's that's
what i'm telling him is
i've i have failed
um and i've and i've had a drink or i've
been drinking
but my drinking again was not to excess
there was no i would never went into
blackouts or anything of that nature i
was disappointed in myself
er for not
not staying there
although when you are
constantly in a position to be harassed
by
your
beloved
other um
what else could i do
i i wanted to be numb i didn't want to
hear that i didn't want to feel that
especially from one
from one who had professed
such love for me but gave me
mostly hatred
uh your honor i'm about to switch
subjects so if this would be a good time
for the lunch break right we started a
little later so i don't mind going a
little further okay if you want to do
that go ahead
uh mr depp uh i'd like to show you
defendants exhibit 161 i believe mr
rottenborn showed you this last week and
again today
yes
yes do you recognize these text messages
as between you and miss heard yes i do
yes i do um why are you informing ms
heard that there's a book called disco
bloodbath
i i at that when i texted her
yeah 2 30 in the afternoon i was uh
i was in a bookstore
um a a used bookstore or a
bookstore that had a lot of first
editions and things like that which was
sort of a passion and
i saw
a book called disco bloodbath and i
thought it was uh
i thought it was a funny
title
i can't say that was
necessarily referencing anything other
than
i thought it was a funny title disco
bloodbath
um it sounded like a sort of a bad
slasher movie to me so i
said just thought you should know that
there exists a book titled disco
bloodbath that's all
and then she
said we need that book
and then she asked me is it about last
friday night by any chance
and then
um
my
my answer
to her
how can you make me smile about such a
hideous moment
the fact is
this this is a light-hearted exchange
that she's
even saying
we need that book then she makes a
reference to last friday
night
which
i don't recall
what last friday night was or whatever
so i just
um
how can you make me smile about such a
hideous moment i i
a hideous moment could have been
some
grotesque thing that we saw on
television
it could have been
anything i i don't recall now but
all i was
saying is and it even says at the end of
my text
that's all
disco bloodbath
you know
um so i this was not a uh
we were not
butting heads in this exchange
whatsoever it was very lighthearted
uh mr deb i'd like to show you
defendants exhibit 375 which is another
document mr rottenborn showed you last
week
yes
um could you please remind the jury
what's reflected in this photograph
um
um on the this this is from australia
uh
on
march 8th i believe it was
where
after my finger had been
the tip of my finger had been
taken off
um
i i began
to
i was in such shock i just started
writing on
the mirror
on the on walls and um
basically what these were for me to miss
heard were reminders
of moments in our
past where
i had
called her
called her
where it was revealed to me even by her
that
she had been caught in
lies that she had told me
so
that's what these are in reference to
the the
the red the lipstick um
that says
call carly simon
call carly simon
she said it better babe
in reference to you're so vain i am
imagining
but that's not i didn't uh
the carly simon message is not mine
that's miss herds
so let's just break this down a little
bit who who wrote the the text that's in
black on the mirror that that would be
me and and what does that say
um
uh she loves
i don't know like naked
hollywood or something
um
an artist
of
i don't know what the rest says but
is
what that is
is
ms heard had come to me
and she was seriously
seemed to be seriously concerned about
how she was
being portrayed in
in hollywood
she was she was concerned that
because she had done films where there
was
[Music]
uh kind of arbitrary nudity and things
of that nature
she had voiced to me that she did not
want to be
she didn't want to be looked upon that
way
in the industry she wanted to be able to
escape
the
the chains of
being objectified
by
the hollywood system which is a
difficult thing for any woman certainly
unfortunately
but she she asked me how
can i
how can i avoid
being stereotyped as the
as the beautiful blonde who
who gets her breasts out or it goes
naked and has to stroke people in
in movies
and i gave her my
advice on it on how on how to avoid it
which i thought was
pretty accurate and uh
it
uh
her ambition was uh stronger than
than um
than what she received from my advice is
is what it was
my advice
that i thought long and hard about
because i did care for her and i did
understand
i didn't want her to have to
do that and
early on in my career
i
i was put in a position where
you know i could have gone on i could
have been
just a guy who was on a tv series for a
couple of years
and then you know what was going to be
left of me was uh
would be on lunch boxes and thermoses
and posters and
teen idol things and i
i've fought that tooth and nail
because i didn't
that's not who i was
so i i
had experienced something similar
in terms of being
looked upon as something that you're not
and so i fought against it in the very
beginning and
it worked out
for me
for you know for a while there and
i was giving it basically the same
advice
now mr depp you said that
you did not write this portion that's in
red here that says
carly
simon said it call carly simon she said
it better babe is that right yes no i
that's that's not mine
um
how do you know that it was misheard
that wrote that
objection lack of foundation
a rule though we can answer it
there are um
it's
well first it doesn't it looks like it's
trying to match my handwriting but my
handwriting is a lot more
of a scribble
um
and also there's another photograph of
this where she went in to make sure that
there were
uh
that
the red
um was more prominent
um
i believe there's also a napkin down
there
where
your honor foundation is referring to
exhibits that are aren't in evidence and
no idea whether they even exist i'll
sustain the objection now next question
was
do you recall whether the lipstick
writing was on the mirror when you wrote
in the black page no of course not no
mr depp i'd like to
show you one of the text messages that
mr rottenborn showed you concerning the
injury to your finger so if we could
please pull up defendants exhibit 398.
um this is a text message from you to dr
kipper that i believe mr rottenborn
showed you on cross-examination do you
remember that
yes okay and
why are you apologizing to dr kipper in
this message
um
i believe that
at that point in in my
brain and in my life and in my heart i
was
um
completely
and utterly frustrated with
how i had to
how i was living my life and
i had had some
disagreement
with
dr kipper
and i was
i was
apologizing to him for having
gone against his uh his wishes
or gone against his
advice let's say
what did you mean when you said i have
chopped off my left middle finger as a
reminder that i should never cut off cut
my right finger off again
it's again it's my way of dealing with
um
dealing with a painful situation it's
it's my way of dealing with a painful
situation where i resort to humor
so
i had lost the tip of my
right finger
and so i'm saying to him
i've now cut off my left finger
to remind me never to cut my right
finger off again
that's
that's not
i mean
when you say i got my finger cut off or
i cut my finger off or this or that it
doesn't necessarily mean that you did it
yourself and again
i'm a guitarist and have been since i
was 12 and that was the only
piece that i
found in my life at the age of 12
where
i knew
what i
i knew who
i could
that i could
escape into
music
and learn music and
the last thing i'm a guitar i mean i
i still play the guitar with it's still
my first love
aside from my children it's
still my first love
there's
no reason in the world why i
literally
would cut my own
finger off to ruin
[Music]
this this
beautiful
opportunity that i was given at 12 to
learn how to play the guitar
um
and and and
again
what why would i
start lopping off digits in my 50s
if i if i um
as mr rottenborn suggests
i'm
a kind of you know
walking tantrum
when i was younger
why
wouldn't i just start chopping off
fingers and
or
some kind of
why would i ruin
the only thing that was really good in
my life aside from
my children so
when this finger went the tip of this
finger went
um
the only thing i could think in my mind
was
thank god it wasn't the left hand which
is the fret hand i'm right-handed so
that's the fret
that's where the fretboard is
if you lose a finger from your left hand
you know i'm not django reinhardt who
had only two fingers to play with
if i'd have lost a finger from here
i would have had to relearn how to play
the guitar all over again
it's just not the case
even though i say i've chopped my finger
off it's like saying you know i i
i
bumped into a knife
or something you know it's it's it's not
i'm not admitting i think if i was going
to admit to someone that i actually
chopped my finger off
this text wouldn't be as it is i think
it would have been a long explanation as
to why i got to that point
but
no i can't take responsibility for
what i now call little richard my
chopped finger
uh mr depp at the time that you sent
this text message to dr kipper um
had you told him what
had actually happened to your right
finger
oh yes
and when did you tell him that
he was aware of that that that day the
day that it happened
malcolm was aware of it
jerry was aware of it stephen was
everyone was aware of it and and
when i
and of course yes when i went to the
doctor
the emergency room i lied to them
because i didn't
i didn't
i didn't think it was
to
cause
a ruckus implicate misheard
and then have eight million stories
out in the press about
how she'd thrown a bottle of vodka at my
at me and it smashed
the
all the bones in the
tip of my finger and
cut off about well it was all sliced
down through you've seen the pictures
it was pretty horrible
um
it was it was
and i
i didn't want to i didn't want to
i didn't want to put her in that
situation i didn't want to put any of us
in that situation i didn't want to put
the film
in that situation
that was why i said it was crushed in an
accordion door and it was only the
second doctor who had uh
who
actually told me what he
what he is your honor hearsay
i haven't finished my sentence how do
you know i'll go for a moment
go ahead
thank you
um
it was
the emergency room doctor was first
the next day i went to see a specialist
a hand
surgeon and this was still in australia
and he had recognized
that
my
excuse for the finger being gone
objection your honor hearsay what the
doctor conveyed to him about his
thoughts on the finger injury that's
classic hearsay uh your honor it's in
the context of medical treatment
i'll sustain that objection
um your honor i think this is a good
stopping all right yeah all right ladies
and gentlemen we'll go ahead and take
our our lunch recess again do not do any
outside um
[Music]
any outside discussions and don't talk
to each other about it okay and we'll
see you after lunch okay
if everybody in the courtroom could
still be quiet please court is in
session thank you
all right so we can take a recess till 2
20. just for planning purposes though i
plan to go to 5 30 today since we had a
late start so just let you know and i
know you plan on having a remote witness
which is fine just let us know so we can
set that up
but also make sure your remote witness
knows that this is a courtroom i don't
expect them to be any outside
uh
noises or anything else going on in
direct attention and also if they would
know that if there's an objection for
them to hold off answering until that's
resolved that goes for all remote
witnesses when we get to them okay all
right see it 220 then thank you
if
one two
what do you see
here
hmm
sure
all right we're ready for the jury then
okay
okay
okay
all right thank you be seated in your
next question
uh
mr depp before the break we were talking
about your how your finger got injured
in australia do you remember that
uh yes okay um i'd like to pull up um
defendants
exhibit 394 please
mr depp do you recall mr rottenborn
showing you this exhibit
on during your cross-examination
yes i do
can you please explain
when relative to your finger injury you
sent this text message
that's the day before
is it am i correct
at the bottom it says i cut the top of
my finger off what should i do except of
course go to a hospital ah australia
exactly
the time difference sorry
uh
yes
that's that's what i said
and so when relative to when your finger
was injured did you send this text
message to your best recollection
this this looks like it's
um
um
at the time
to me i i'm
and in the middle here it says
her obsession with herself is far more
important she's so [ __ ] ambitious
she's so desperate for success and fame
that's probably why i was acquired made
what did you mean by that
unfortunately i meant exactly
um
i meant
exactly
what i said
in this text it seems it would
it had become clear
that they were um
she seemed to
take more care in
and importance in um
going on auditions getting
going to
the met ball or going to any any sort of
uh
premiere or opening or
whatever
where she could be um
i believe he was responding to what he
meant by what he wrote in his text
messages he said i meant exactly what
the word said and now he's going to be
all right i'll sustain the next
question thank you mr roddenborn
sir if you could just answer the
question mr debt please direct your
attention just to your attorney okay
uh
mr depp last week mr rottenborn showed
you an audio recording where you
referenced your your finger getting cut
off in australia do you recall that
yes okay um i'd like to play a different
portion of that recording um that came
before the portion that mr rottenborn
played so if we could please pull up
plaintiff's exhibit 343
and we will be playing the portion from
at one hour 54 minutes 11 seconds
to 1 hour 56 minutes 10 seconds
it's early
it's quick it's so not you're not
interested in not fighting you are
guaranteeing a fight
when you do that and i tell i've told
you this so many times
you guarantee if you were interested in
not fighting
you would be respectful if you needed
the space
to make you would be careful not to
perpetuate the fight longer by saying i
need
i need a few minutes and then actually
honoring that how can i trust you
that it will be a few minutes when
you've done this in the past and
disappeared for hours
you know i got mad at you in australia
about this i said baby i want to trust
you it's hard for me not to try and work
it out if you want to be the person
that's like i need to cool down
help me do that give that to you but i
can't give it to you if you always let
me down and [ __ ] up and forget because i
gave you a time limit because i said
i'll be back in three minutes so i'm
just no it's different if it happens
it's different you never
if it happens i'm just gonna say look i
need some time
that's it
i'm telling you
that
will
make it worse
no
i guarantee you it will
if you're if you're [ __ ] throwing
punches i'm not talking about throwing
punches i'm talking about an argument
right
in arguments you tend to throw punches
i'm talking about arguments i'm not
talking about the times when it's quite
physical i'm talking about arguments i'm
talking about arguments i'm talking
about arguments
yes in our argument earlier and earlier
and earlier now you split you take off
right away
you don't deal with the issue you don't
deal with the confrontation and you
split
whether it is and then you do it for an
undetermined amount of time you do it
without actually respecting when you do
give me a time like say i need a few
minutes you never
uh mr deb whose voices can you hear in
that audio recording
myself
and
there was a mention about miss heard
getting mad about something in australia
what would what did miss hurd get mad at
you about in australia
there were
there were many
there were many instances
where ms heard
would
get
upset angry
and
argumentative and
violent in australia there were many
there were many times
i i
the one that
was the
the day
when my finger
tip of my finger disappeared
um
that had to do with a phone call
when she arrived in australia she
complained that uh
an attorney
who was
explaining to her
um
the uh
uh objective objection your honor is
hearsay as to what he alleges her
attorney was explaining to her that's
clearly we can move on your honor yes
ma'am um
in the context of this audio recording
that we just heard what to your
understanding is miss heard referencing
when she says you split
i would leave i would excuse myself from
the
situation
um i would try to get away so that
so that nothing escalated
because if given the chance uh to
allow things to escalate ms heard would
take it to the
very extreme
um but she ended up with my
finger being chopped off
so i'd rather thought it was the best
idea to avoid things like that
mr depp i'd like to show you what's been
marked as defendant's exhibit 272 i
believe this is another document that
you saw during your cross-examination
do you recognize these text messages
yes
and this these were after um your detox
on the island is that right
that's correct
now where it says here this was the
right thing to do to speed up the
process what are you referring to there
i
when we were
on the island and
i was going through the process of
detox the detoxing from
the opiates
which was a very
unpleasant and
powerful
painful process
it it wasn't
it wasn't um
it wasn't working
with
misheard there
i i could not properly
detox
um
as
every day was a
another problem or this or that um
so
i asked
i asked we leave the island and go back
to
los angeles
and i asked miss heard
if she would please
allow me to
get a a
bungalow at the beverly hills hotel
where she and her friends could go
for
i needed five days six days seven days
anything i could get
where i could finish the detox
by myself without any
unnecessary interruptions or unpleasant
interruptions
um to which she replied that she was
felt like i was throwing her out and
abandoning her and after all she had
done for me when
the fact is though no matter what i
wrote to her mother and to her i
i needed the time
because she
i was
i would have gone straight back to the
pills
i would have not been able to detox
properly without that time alone and um
she reluctantly gave me the time
and uh i sent her and her friends too to
uh
beverly hills hotel and um
in a bungalow and
went through the detox by myself in the
in penthouse 3 for the next five or six
days
[Music]
mr depp last week mr rottenborn showed
you a video that was taken of yourself
where you're slamming some cabinets do
you recall that
yes i do uh first of all where are you
in that video
that's uh the kitchen at
a house that i've
on sweetsurf
that i've lived in for since
mid 90s
and do you recall what you were upset
about in that video
attraction leading
overruled
i don't recall
as i don't know the date of
um there's no metadata that i
um i'm aware of for that tape also
um apparently looking for any metadata
is impossible as it is not our own
i'll sustain the objection you want to
ask the question
what do you remember
what if anything do you remember being
upset about that resulted in what was
seen in that video
i can't recall if it was bad news
about my
mother's health
i can't recall if if it was something to
do with
my former business managers
um
you know finding out that they've taken
me for a very nasty ride
i don't recall exactly what it was about
what i do know is that it didn't
have anything to do with her objection
beyond the scope of the question
overruled i'll allow it it's fine
there was nothing between us before she
entered that room
it was me alone
uh
okay
do you know where miss heard was before
before she entered the room
um i assumed that she was up in the
you know she'd gotten out of bed and
gotten dressed and come downstairs
mr deb earlier today mr rottenborn
played a recording where you can hear
miss heard um seeming to claim that you
put a cigarette out of her on her do you
remember that i remember hearing that
yes um i'd like to play you another
recording which is plaintiff's exhibit
365.
okay
and this is for the record an 11 second
recording so we'll be putting in the
entire all right any objection to 365.
all right 365 in evidence
couch
couch
couch
you give me one couch i gave you three
other couches two two touches what do
you want
please give me a couch
what do you want couch
what do you want i want couch
i'm on couch yeah agree please though
you said you agreed because you're right
you started talking
you want we'll stop right
here
yes
your honor she says this is 11. that's
been nasty and provoking it's mean
spirited
and then no i'm not saying that
i'm sorry i'm sorry i think i misspoke
it i may have been 45 i may have
misremembered it
i apologize i misremembered all right
it's an evidence
could we ask them to move the media
players
okay okay um
can we play that thank you
couch
couch
couch
you give me one couch i gave you three
other couches two two touches
please give me a couch
what do you want couch
what do you want i want couch
i want couch
agree please so you said you agreed
because you started talking
it was celebrated
yes
everything you've said has been nasty
and provoking
and mean-spirited
and meant no i'm not saying that you
asked me yours
by the way you just threw a [ __ ]
cigarette on me
mr depp do you recognize what's in that
recording
do i recognize what's in the recording
yes
um
[Music]
it seems pretty clear that she's
ordering me to the couch
and i didn't want to go through with any
again
avoiding
confrontation trying to avoid
confrontation in any way
um
i can
certainly say that
without hesitation
there is no
way
under the sun that i would
flick a cigarette at her or burn her
with a cigarette if i flicked ashes
and an ash
got on her but she's certainly not
screaming out in pain as if a cigarette
is being put out on her
that's
ludicrous
do you recall the situation that's
reflected in that audio recording
i believe that's montreal uh excuse me
toronto
um
which was right after the venice film
festival it's we were at the toronto
film
festival mr depp i'd like to ask you
about a couple text messages from may 2
20 excuse me may 22nd 2016 that mr
rottenborn asked you about
um earlier
um and before i do could you please
remind the jury what was going on
between you and miss herds really
between you and miss heard on may 22nd
2016.
on may 22nd
on may 21st
um
i had
she wanted i hadn't seen
[Music]
her since the
since the 22nd of april her birthday
which was when i left at
4 30 in the morning um
objection your honor this is cumulative
he's already gone through all this in
his direct examination and she asked him
what was happening on may 22nd and he's
getting into what happened on may 21st
we've already been through this yeah i i
believe that we're he's providing
context for where they were on the 22nd
but
um if you could
mr dub please explain what was where you
were on the 22nd of
may in 2016.
as far as i can remember them on may
22nd 2016 i was
preparing either preparing to leave for
new york
for uh
rehearsals and then a tour with the
hollywood vampires
um i was either preparing to leave or i
was
had left
could we please pull up defendants
exhibit 736 please
and
do you recall sending this text message
to ms heard
on may 22nd 2016 at 6 19 pm
yes i do
okay
um what did you mean when you told her
nothing i have to say
to you should elicit anything but a
sense of ease
it was essentially for me it was a
i was bringing up
what i'd spoken to her about before
which was
a peaceful
resolution to
the
problems the peaceful resolution in
terms of a peaceful
and
private and quiet and calm
divorce
um
and so that's why i say
it shouldn't elicit anything but a sense
of ease
because
it was not about
i didn't want to argue i didn't want
anything but to
end
the marriage
in the
kindest way possible
for
all
her family my family her
myself
etc
and what did you mean when you said all
my love and profound apologies
profound apologies is that
it
just
didn't work
we just
could not work there was
no way and
i had to try to put a peaceful end a
peaceful stop to
[Music]
the endless
um
the endless opportunities for
for
these
constant arguments
if i didn't put a stop to it then
i mean if
if i didn't try to put a peaceful stop
to it peaceful into it and it
if you don't stop it yourself
it'll stop you
it'll stop you and
and you don't know what that could be
but it's
it was horrific
and i wanted her out
of it and i wanted out of it
no one deserves
to live
like that no one deserves to live like
that not her not me not anyone
so i just wanted
a smooth
exit for both of us that's all i was
looking for
mr depp
yes or
last week
mr rottenborn played a clip from an
audio recording where miss heard
told you that you vomit in your sleep a
lot do you remember that recording
yes i do and what's your response to
that
someone
when someone tells you that you vomit
because you didn't tell me i heard it in
court i
when someone brings up the fact that you
vomit
in your sleep every night
and
well at first i think you'd be aware of
it
and also i think the first thing that i
would do is seek medical attention
didn't exist i'd never vomited in my
sleep every night i i
there were times when i would get yes
physically
ill
from the
endless
uh
shots that you take
when you're just
you can't
you're you're unable to take it anymore
and
it does affect you physically
after a while you
so
i would
have to leave
and go and
um
vomit
in
when fights got into these
surreal and absurd and horrible places
um but
it still
confounds me as to why
she would record that
i don't know why
anyone would record that
mr depp the the portion
the clip that mr rottenborn played was
from defendants exhibit 839 and just for
the record this is a portion of a larger
recording which is reflected in
plaintiff's exhibit
342. so with the court's permission i'd
like to play
a
clip from plaintiff's exhibit 342.
and the word the portion i'd like to
play is that 19 minutes 40 seconds
to 25 minutes 25 seconds do we have 342
already in evidence or i don't believe
so your honor no so you want to put 342
it's just the entire
audio in
yes i don't believe that there's anyone
else in this audio recording your honor
i don't believe i hear this before okay
342 any objection
as long as there's
no one else in the audio
we can we can confirm afterwards so if
if your honor would if it's more
comfortable we can put it in as 342a
okay
and what was the let's put 342a what's
the i'm sorry what's the part that
you're going to it's uh 19 minutes 40
seconds to 25 minutes 25 seconds
all right and there's just the two of
them in this excerpt that's correct
that's 342 a in evidence then thank you
okay do you understand why 10 minutes
downstairs didn't seem real i don't care
did you know what i said i don't care
okay you do there's plenty of things
you've done plenty of things you've
[ __ ] done
absolutely [ __ ] lies i didn't ever
talk with you about it so anyway don't
leave it so i'll see you in a bit is
that what matters
your life
is this what matters to you your party
i never led you
and what we're talking about tonight is
what
who are you
why why are you doing this
why
why what is it that is so important
always to run away to
why
[Music]
i you asked me once not to leave and i'm
asking you so why every five seconds do
i get i'm leaving because there's a
[ __ ] movie party i gotta go to i have
never prioritized you behind that
and you of all people of all people all
this talk
about not being that guy you have done
nothing but over the last two days but
tell me that your movie parties were
more important including the night
before last
when i said to you the same thing say
and today you apologize said i love you
i'm so sorry and then and then today it
takes you two seconds it takes you 20
seconds at most to go [ __ ] that i hate
you i don't want to be with you goodbye
i'm leaving i'm running away but i'm not
running i'm walking away
for sure
i don't want to be with you
i don't
i really don't
then if you don't want to be with me in
life
then you need to
actually
do it you need to actually take off your
brain
and forget that five hours ago you said
the opposite otherwise you can't keep
throwing that around
you can't keep saying to me that this is
something you care about
is that what it's worth to you
yeah
yeah for you
from all this [ __ ]
these rules all these rules because i
asked you to stay
because i asked you to stay no because
you you're [ __ ] what was it what was
it when you asked me
what was it when you asked me to stay
in australia you said you promised me
not to leave
you you said
you promised me not to leave what i do i
thought you would change what did i do
what did i do
did i stay or did i leave you
did i stay or did i leave you stayed and
you didn't change and you were [ __ ]
scared and you asked you were coming so
i stayed and i've been in [ __ ] ever
since which is why you told me about
every other day how you couldn't imagine
your life without me including today
so which one does that seem normal to
you does that seem normal to you
they got you told me tonight that you
couldn't imagine your life without me
and now you're throwing your ring on the
ground does that seem normal that's how
you tell me that seems silver you see
you seem normal definition of normal you
does that seem normal
you does that seem normal to you
borderline personality disorder i'm
borderline personality disorder now
without question when i've been
consistent all night saying don't go
don't [ __ ] this all up i'm not fighting
with you anymore
i've been saying this to you the whole
night i'm really sorry we disagreed
you're not perfect i said this two hours
ago
i'm not perfect you're not perfect i
love you but we don't
have to do this every time we disagree
no don't please we do please
come here and you have please come here
please come here i'm not insulting you i
have not been insulting you i love you
johnny what do you mean me to do i love
you
stop
smack me on the euro again
i don't know i'll smack my ear again
in my [ __ ] brain
you like that
kind of perch god damn parent or a
[ __ ] weird frenzied dog no it won't
be it you know
goddamn
[ __ ] lover
uh
i'm making this up
what are you and miss heard discussing
in this recording
is a
another
argument that
is apparently not an argument to her
the screeching
of her voice
the the
demand
that things go her away and only her way
i was
i was done and i think i stated clearly
i don't want to be with you i don't want
to be with you i i i'm not gonna be a
parrot on a
or or some you know little dog that runs
through oops for you i ain't gonna do
that and i want it out
she said take your ring off she still
wouldn't let me i did and she still
wouldn't let me leave
um
so it's just another
example of um
kind of being
nailed in one spot and not allowed to uh
do anything but
react
to
her
screaming and um
screaming like a banshee and then
telling me to calm down
when i had been pretty calm i thought
where were you trying to go
if you can recall
anywhere
away
and why did you ask ms hurd if she
wanted to smack you in the ear again
she had given me a good chop in the ear
you know
one of those were
um
leaves you ringing you know
and um
it was not long before that and so i
thought
maybe this will make you happy
will it make you happy to would you like
to hit me in the ear again would that
would that
make you feel better
will that make you stop
this
would have done anything to have stopped
outside of
taking anything to some physical level i
disagreed with that wholeheartedly
that's not me
that's not who i've ever been it's not
who i'll ever be
mr depp um i'm gonna play another audio
recording this is a different portion
from what mr rottenborn played for you
today it's dx58598
i believe the portion mr rottenboard
played was designated 598b so this will
be
598c
um and first i'd like to play the
portion from 31 minutes 14 seconds to 33
minutes four seconds
all right any objection to 598c
um and then we will go on and play the
second portion which is
56 minutes 27 seconds
to 59 minutes 54 seconds
okay
all right 598 c in evidence
right like you build i build you know it
isn't like at one moment either of us
sign a certificate of saying or like
sign the contract or
say okay now i'll blow that no
so acting as though there's a choice
between the two is irrelevant
i'm not asking you to stay
over having a bloodbath i'm asking you i
mean over walking away i'm not asking
you to have a bloodbath or for walking
away i'm asking you to work it out
over prolonging it and making it bigger
right but if i mean at least that's how
i see it indeed but if things get heated
yeah and it looks like it's going
somewhere nasty and the name calling
begins
and all that stuff i've got to get away
because it i don't want to be ever in a
situation again like that
never me too
me too
that's that's
don't freak out if we do have a fight
and i walk away i'm not
going to do that i'm asking you to stay
when you feel
you are
also in the interest of working it out i
think it's a good idea for us to take
a moment or two or i mean a moment and
take some time
take some time to think by ourselves
without being
you know barraged by each other's
[ __ ] [ __ ] whatevers
i just i just let's take a let's take a
break from it
and then come back try and be calm
and and walk through the thing
but but
i'm not gonna stand and fight with you i
will not you can call me a coward i
don't even call me anything you want all
those names do it but i will not do it
again
please stop asking i mean please can you
stop for the sake of this conversation
i'm just saying i won't do it again
okay great then let's take our space
then let's not do this anymore because
i'm really getting frustrated and i'm
really really really sick of this
argument i'm sorry okay so let me go and
you go and i'll speak to you in a couple
hours
okay
okay
why are you saying stop may i go
it causes me so much stress when you
when you walk away from me with that
it's like you're you don't understand
how much worse you're making this
please you're making it worse for me
okay i'm sorry for you
please i'm only trying to tell you
so that you know you're causing me
immense stress right now when you walk
away like that
there's no reason to be mad i can say
goodbye
i haven't walked away you're not saying
goodbye you won't let me [ __ ] leave
let me leave
stop rushing me stop pushing me in the
corner and then poking me with the dick
and then saying why are you saying the
words you want me to say
stop poking me stop rushing me stop
throwing me against the wall i'm going
what you like that wall you don't like
the [ __ ] wall
stop pushing me
i'm rushing you i said i need space
i don't want this conversation anymore
right now i need space and i will take
my space whether you like it or not
i will take it
and you will take your space
but if you keep
halting i'm not doing anything
and continuing i'm not ready
i'm begging you to stop i don't okay
stop just i'm stopped
stop
now i have to go
okay so we will speak to each other in a
couple of hours
okay
i hope you have
some kind of revelation
makes you feel better
you know
i hope i do too but uh we'll just see
when i get home we'll just talk or we
won't talk or we you know we'll
finish this or we won't finish it
but this is not well this is not
happiness this is not this please stop
doing this please you're
so much [ __ ] stressed i'm going to
die
i'm going to [ __ ] die you're causing
me so much stress please stop
please
i feel like i have heart attacks almost
every day please stop please stop doing
it please don't be so [ __ ] mean
you're [ __ ] bullied stop
please stop i've been begging you not to
fight i just said can we please have a
normal argument just even a normal
conversation it's like a normal argument
and for the last hour i've been begging
you to please just leave it at that
let's just go on with our night i would
have been able to come in with you we
would have been able to let it go in a
few minutes it would have been fine it
would just if we allowed ourselves out
[ __ ] normal arguments
please you're killing me with this
you're killing me
you're
[ __ ] killing me yeah [ __ ]
sean
could you uh
please
i want you to just go i want you to take
your medicine
or whatever i'm sorry that i've upset
you yeah i think
thank you sean i'm ready to go thank you
so much
mr deb in the beginning well first of
all do you know where you are when
you're having this discussion with miss
heard
the only
excuse me the only clue that i have
is that um
sean is
being called i had called sean and said
to
drive her
home
or
i believe it was probably at sweet sir
so then she could drive back he would
drive her back to
downtown
house 3
with a
she didn't seem in any shape to drive
to me
and earlier in the clip there was a
reference to
a bloodbath what does that mean in the
context of that conversation
i i don't know
again
it seems like some word that was uh
because
he said he doesn't know all right i'll
sustain jack's next next question
mr depp at the end of the day on
thursday uh mr rottenborn played an
audio recording for you where you were
heard saying you were going to hurt
yourself do you remember that
yes i do okay and i'm not going to play
that audio recording again it seemed
upsetting to you but i do want to ask
you a couple questions about that okay
sure
um could you please tell the jury when
that recording is is from
the recording is from
um
july
of 2016.
this was um
a couple of months a few months after
the
uh
the restraining order had been
put on me i had been on tour
through europe
and then coming through the states i i
got messages from
christian carino who was both of our
former agent um
saying that ms hurd
wanted to meet with me in san francisco
because we had a
one of our last dates on the tour was
san francisco
and i was confused as to why
missouri wanted to meet with me
especially since i was under a court
order not to come within i don't know
100 200 feet or something for of her
um
so at first i i said uh objection your
honor the question was simply do you
remember when that was from yeah
okay
so
where were you when that recording was
taken
that was in san francisco
at a hotel room
uh
so we went to a hotel room so that we
could finish the discussion that you
wanted to have with me
and
how did that discussion go
not particularly well i was
quite confused as to why
i had been summoned
to her um
at that point since
all the news was uh
all the news was just about the fact
that i had
allegedly
done all these horrible things to her
and
so i was talked into going there i went
and met with her in hopes that
she would
retract
her
lies
that the world was now
fed that had been fed um
and in no way was she uh
ready to do that and i couldn't
understand why i was there
every everything had been taken
from me
um
my children couldn't escape the fact
that uh all this had gone down so i was
trying to the question was how did the
discussion go and he's talking about his
children yes i'm way beyond the scope
just talking sir just wait for the
objection okay i think he's describing
the context around that conversation
it's way beyond the scope of the
question all right i'll sustain the
objection next question
mr deb why were you threatening to hurt
yourself in that audio recording
in fact i wasn't threatening to hurt
myself i
thought that miss heard had
brought me to
san francisco at that point it was clear
under false pretenses
i don't know what she was after
so
i
i had a
knife in my pocket and i just took the
knife out and i said here
cut me
that's
that's what you want to do ultimately
you've taken everything
you want my blood
take it
have my blood
and then she said no no
and then i said look if
if you don't if you're not to take it
you want it i know you want it that's
all i've got left
take it
if she wasn't going to do it i would
have done it
because that's
psychologically emotionally where i was
i was at the end
i was
broken
not only had i
had to deal with
everything from coming in from
you know arrows from all over the world
but now she's
i don't know what she was trying to do
so i just thought the only answer is
here cut me
take my blood that's all that's all i've
got left to give you
and
obviously
there was no threat to misheard with
that knife it was about
spilling my blood because i thought
that's what she the only thing she
didn't have
at that point
and i was uh
i was i was broken and uh
really just at the end just at the end
i couldn't take it anymore
it's uh
i thought
i mean everybody i know that that's his
job but i that that was quite a cruel
objection your honor or well being on
this okay i'll sustain the objection
next question
um finally i'd like to play a portion
from plaintiff's exhibit 357
specifically the portions at 18 minutes
43 seconds
through 21 minutes 46 seconds
357 is that correct 357 yes
all right so is this going to be another
one where it's going to be an a or is
this going to be all that's going to be
offered
um
why don't we go with aid
okay can you give me the numbers again
just so i have them for the record
what are you going to play
um it is um 357 beginning at 18 minutes
43 seconds
through 21 minutes 46 seconds
all right any objection to 357a
all right 357a in evidence
it's been going on too long albert and
we just got to stop this
it's gonna stop it
i don't know how to get my um reputation
back
we write a letter together
[Music]
saying that we're going to take this out
of the public eye
saying that we're trying to work this
out on our own
saying
that the media has created such a
[ __ ] hateful storm
that it's sickening
that we love each other
and that we want to make sure each other
is okay
have we had fights in the past that we
had this or whatever [ __ ] it they
already know all that [ __ ] don't matter
here's the deal no it matters
i have been i am that
you have no idea every ounce of my
credibility
has been taken from i mean and done soon
and dishonest right
you know
the abuse the abuse thing is is is we've
got to deal with that yeah
we've got to deal with that um anybody
uh my credit is it's my credibility you
know what i
mean why did you put that out there i
did not you hurt me your team forced you
by going on the offense i didn't force
you to start
i promise
look up the timeline to be sick
everything
i did not put this anywhere i didn't let
me talk to the [ __ ] team i did not
call the cops
i o called the cops
you told i would call the cops
and i did not give them any statement
when they came i've been trying to
protect you you told io to call the cops
what was happening yeah oh i'm sorry i'm
sorry because the last time that it got
crazy between us i really didn't think i
was gonna lose my life and i thought you
would do it on accident
and i told you that
i said oh my god i thought the first
time amber i lost a [ __ ] finger man
come on
i had a [ __ ] i had a [ __ ] a
mineral can't hear a count of mineral
spirits thrown at my nose
you can please tell people that it was a
fair fight and see what the see what the
jury and judge think tell the world
johnny tell them johnny depp i joined up
man i'm i'm a victim too of domestic
violence
you know it's a fair fight it seems how
many people believe or side with you
it doesn't matter if i verify my ass
would you know exactly
mr deb when did you have the
conversation reflected in this recording
with miss heard
i don't recall exactly when it was
what's your best estimate
my best estimate
is that it was um
before
long before the
while quite a while before the meeting
in san francisco in
july
excuse me
how far after may 21st 2016 do you think
that conversation was
objection calls for speculation
sorry he said he doesn't remember when
it was i'm asking for his best estimate
allowed if you can answer it this way
so could you ask it again i was
distracted how long after may 21st 2016
do you believe that conversation took
place
i would i would say there was uh
not
too far maybe
a couple of months it was far enough to
where
the um
the world media
was already bombarding me
so
um
it was it was an attempt to try to
make all
objections
all right i'll sustain the objection
next question
what are you referring to when you said
you and miss heard will write a letter
together
i was trying to make a peaceful
settlement
and what are you referring to when you
say you lost a finger
a very large bottle of vodka severing my
index of my middle finger
in australia
and what were you referring to when you
said a can of mineral spirits was thrown
at your nose
one of the
arguments on the island were misheard
had uh
been the howling
at me with some argument and um
she picked up a can of
mineral spirits about yay big and uh
just
heaved it at me and uh it uh struck me
on the bridge of the nose
and the right there you know the
forehead
and what did you say in response when
miss heard said tell the world johnny
tell them johnny depp i johnny depp a
man
i'm a victim too of domestic violence
i said yes
i am
i have nothing further your honor sir
you can have a seat next to your
attorney please
thank you all right your next witness
ben king
is somebody going to go get mr king
you can take it with you or usually you
leave it there
so
so
in this case
uh
all right and good afternoon mr king
good afternoon
would you please state your full name
for the record ben king
and mr king uh can you briefly tell us
where you're where you're from
london central london okay
and can you tell us a little bit about
your background what's your occupation
i'm a house manager
a personal assistant presently with a an
individual who also lives in central
london
okay can you lean into the microphone a
little bit yeah sure
sorry here we go
uh did you say you're a house manager
that's right personal assistant house
manager
and can you just tell
those of us in the courtroom who aren't
familiar what does that mean
i work presently for a gentleman who's
in the entertainment industry who and i
manage his property at large apartment
in central london
take care of the daily needs in running
of that oversight of their staff
and traveling with him when needed and
things like that
and how long have you been in this
occupation
oh um
since
about 1991 i started in private services
if you like
um
in-house management in butlering in
you know that stuff
uh typically based around london
correct i started work in in london was
my first big job at buckingham palace
funnily enough
for four years and then i continued in
different positions full-time and
and
self-employed
freelance capacity and for many years as
well
okay
just generally can you tell us and
without getting into any specifics but
what what type of people would you say
you typically provide these services for
generally high net worth people
individuals or families
residencies
okay
are you familiar with the plaintiff in
this case johnny depp yes i am yeah
and how are you familiar with mr depp
i
met and worked
for mr depp in
2014
and subsequently a couple of times after
that
okay can you briefly just
explain to the jury how it came to be
that you were working for mr depp
sure
um
yes i uh at that point i was working in
a freelance self-employed capacity uh i
was a lot of my jobs came through
friends of friends
you know personal
recommendations etc
and
i was asked by a friend of a friend on
this occasion would i be available a uh
to go and manage a property where mr
depp was going to be staying for
about a month in central london
was i available what are they willing to
do it and i was available at that point
and so i said yes i'd
yeah absolutely
and just to make sure we're on the same
page what time frame are we talking
about here
that was august um 2014.
okay
and did you in fact end up working uh
for mr depp in that time frame i did yes
now just to clarify uh were you employed
by mr depp no so so who was your
employer
i was paid through a large hotel which
was close by to the house who also
uh
they they
provided the housekeeper who was working
with us for that month as well so i was
paid through them
okay
can you just generally explain to us
what kind of work you were doing uh for
mr depp and miss heard in this time
frame sure yeah it was it's set up at
the house basically um
sorry
setting up the house initially
which which meant ahead of the
principles arriving
uh which meant
making sure all the linens were in place
for the bedrooms it was it was a
sizeable property
and just
organizing everything ahead of their
arrival
once they arrived it was the management
of that property the oversight of it and
the
day-to-day running
some service you know like butler
service and
managing the housekeeper
day-to-day through that whole month
and when you refer to the principles who
are you referring to
mr depp and miss hurt
uh
where exactly were you working in london
at this point uh just kind of describe
for us the house this house this was in
mayfair is a large townhouse
in an old building but it was very
contemporary inside a modern
furnished
very modern sort of way
um quite spacious maybe four or five
bedrooms i think a small indoor pool a
small gym
quite an open plan layout throughout the
house
okay
um and how long how long were they there
for the month essentially yes
okay
can you tell us just generally what
hours you would typically work in a day
while you were working for them in
london in this timeframe yeah um
approximately it depended on what was
going on but i mean generally seven or
eight in the morning till
seven or eight in the evening typically
there was a chef employed as well
russell brilliant chef
he um he
he tended to say after i left in the
evening he would cook dinner serve
dinner and
thankfully cleaned up after dinner so i
i could leave sort of early to mid
evening usually most days
unless we had guests
sorry unless there were guests or other
things going on
during your time
managing the house for mr dev and this
herd in 2014. did you have occasion to
observe the interactions between mr duff
and mr
yes absolutely
yeah how often
most daily i would say pretty much most
days through that period
and did you yourself interact with mr
deputy yes also daily i would say
which of them would you say or did you
see one of them more often than the
other
ms heard was that mr depp was um the
reason i think they rented the house was
because mr depp was
working
at a studio he was i think it was
mordecai the movie
so miss hurt was there at the house most
of the days mr depp often went to work
and came back later on in that evening
that day
okay
uh how would you generally describe
the the
interactions that you observed between
mr depp and ms hurd
initially very sort of loving towards
each other you know
nice couple um mr debt was always
a gentleman and and keen to make sure
miss heard was taken care of
anything she needed often pour a glass
of wine for her
just
nice you know pleasant
uh how about your own interactions with
the couple how did you get along with
them both i think very well and
yeah i
they were really open to me and
i mean my background was quite formal so
it was
that it was quite an informal setting it
was i was able to ask questions
to either of them
misheard especially it was really
helpful to get
information about what time they wanted
dinner you know basic stuff like that
or anything it was it was good
interaction all the time
with the both of them
okay now you mentioned uh you mentioned
wine
uh can you tell us uh to what extent did
you observe either of them consume
alcohol over the course of these four
weeks
sure um before i when i started that
when i was taking that job on i
i was told i think by mr depp's
assistant
that he was
oh
sorry
can you answer without telling what you
were told
same objection he's explaining what he's
been told now he said i was informed i
don't think it's offered for the truth
your honor i think it's just offered for
to to to explain his own uh behavior
towards the couple um
can we approach okay
all right so so mr king i'm moving past
the conversation let's not touch on that
um but just in general can you describe
the alcohol consumption that you
personally observed and what you
personally witnessed sure
um i didn't see mr her
mr
consume any alcohol that during that
time in london um
i i there was a large consignment of
wine that had been delivered to the
house at the start of the visit
many cases that i had to store had to
find a place to store
and
generally speaking on a day-to-day about
one or two bottles of red wine were
consumed
per day
i think that's fair to say
did you ever observe mr depp drink any
of the wine
no i didn't
did you ever observe miss her drink any
of the wine yes i did
regularly
daily
now i think you already testified that
you
observed interactions with mr gap and
misheard and you generally found them to
be friendly is that fair very much so
yes
um were there any exceptions to that
towards me
oh i'll rephrase did you ever observe
any arguments between the two yes i did
i'll allow this one
you can answer oh yes i did yeah okay
and can you describe for us the
arguments that you observed
i can describe two of them um certainly
uh there were a few arguments on that
during that month
let's just start with those two okay
uh the first one i remember was a an
evening actually they were both
the ones i recall were and i was close
to were evenings
uh this first particular evening
the couple were due to go out
for dinner i i guess um
i know the car was waiting in the
in the little courtyard there ready for
them to go and security were waiting to
to take them
i was waiting to see them out into the
cars at the foot of the on the ground
level ground floor level
to uh wait to see them out essentially
and i heard the first thing i heard was
misheard shouting upstairs in the master
suite where they were getting ready to
to leave i heard her shout something i
don't recall what you know i was in the
vicinity i wasn't really there to listen
and
i
heard footsteps
loud footsteps sort of going across a
there's a like a
corridor if you like the top of those
stairs that went
around the master suite
uh
loud footsteps and then more footsteps
following more
shouting
and that that sort of went on for some
time i mean i i knew that they what time
they needed to leave i don't recall what
time that was but they
i knew they need they were supposed to
have left already
and
it went on for a bit
do you recall how that first uh fight or
argument resolved
no not necessarily i mean i know that
they left eventually albeit late uh i
don't know how it really resolved
because i sort of made myself busy but
not going too far away from the door
make sure i saw them out
all right and then what about the second
argument that you mentioned
second one i was
pretty much in the same vicinity the
same room on the ground floor
again i would the couple were in the the
tv room i think which was off the main
sitting room early evening and i was
going about my
early evening duties replenishing drinks
close by
um you know lighting the fire lighting
candles whatever it might have been
i was close enough to
to hear miss heard say
why did you take your hand away from me
johnny don't you do you love me anymore
like not in a playful way i might add
um
and i think he replied of course i do
don't be silly yeah of course i do and
it kind of launched from that point
and at one point mr depp got up and went
to the bathroom or went upstairs and i
was sort of scuttling around out of the
way because i you know i wasn't there
listening i was just there doing my
stuff
in and around them
yeah it was a
strange sort of banal way to start an
argument but
how would you describe miss herd's tone
when she said
why did you take your hand away johnny
accusatory spoiled teenage child
maybe is that fair
it did pretty you know not playfully
let's put it that way more angrily
um over the course of the four weeks in
august and september 2014 when you were
working with mr deputy in london yes did
you ever observe any physical violence
of any kind between the two of them no i
didn't
did you ever observe any injuries on
either one of them no neither of them
okay
after those four weeks um did you ever
work for mr depp or mr again i did a
couple of occasions the following year
was the first one
the following spring
okay and where was that
in australia
and what is it uh was it unusual for you
to be in australia
in australia maybe but not unusual for
me to travel with for clients from my
assignments to wherever it was needed
okay
um
how how exactly did it come about that
you were in australia with mr daphne
um towards the end of the london visit
uh mr deputy kindly said
we you know thanks so much for looking
after us we really like you maybe if
you're free next year and we can arrange
it we can make it happen
perhaps you'll be able to come to
australia with us i've got to film
pirates five
so i said great i'd love to you know
obviously
i was freelance at the time so it was
going going to be about four months work
i think it was builders so
i thought yes
i wouldn't mind some of that thank you
very much
and uh where in australia were you
staying there's a gold coast
yeah bits of brisbane area um brisbane
was the main airport so it's about an
hour's drive south of brisbane
and you recall when you arrived
i arrived on february the 4th i know i
flew on that day
okay
how did your job responsibilities in
australia compare to your job
responsibilities uh in london much the
same just on a bigger scale the house
was larger
there was a bit more setup to do
but essentially the same oversight of
the house you know
responsible for it during the whole
the whole gig
and were you employed by mr depp or miss
heard
no who were you employed by
essentially by disney the production
company affiliated with disney who were
making the movie i think their name was
herschel was the production company
okay now i think you said you arrived in
australia on february 4th 2015. could i
have that right yes okay uh how about mr
depp and miss heard when did they arrive
uh the setup for me for us was about a
few weeks i think they they arrived
towards the end of february
2015.
and between your arrival and their
arrival
what have you been doing
just setting up the house i lived on
site uh there was a guest house on site
a two-bedroom single-story guest house
that i stayed in for those first couple
of weeks uh setting up the house and
just getting everything ready
during that time and then i moved out to
apartments which we all had
we i mean a lot of the crew
the chef had an apartment we all had
apartments about a 30 minute drive south
of south of the house okay
and so we're talking about this house in
australia um so can you kind of describe
that property to us
yes it was a large house
on
a few acres of land um a three-story
house five bedrooms
with two or three buildings on within
the grounds
as well
a good-sized house
beautiful house beautiful location
how many entrances would you say it had
entrances many i mean
many on
certainly on the lower ground level out
to the garden
on the first or on the main floor level
there was many entrances
i mean every room in that house had a
balcony at least
every room on the lower ground floor had
had a sliding door or a door out
the utility room the garage that
the
gym the
every everything
uh obviously the front door
many on the main level the large glass
sliding doors out to the pool area which
had a gazebo and
and it steps down to the
to the ground
okay and once mr depp and miss heard
arrived to stay at this house um was
anybody else staying in the house
staying in the house now in
was anybody else staying on the grounds
on the property yes i mean there was a
couple there county care taking couple
uh sean and his wife
sandra who worked for the the owner of
the house they lived on on site
essentially all the time they were there
pretty much throughout
um and their house was
whatever a couple of hundred yards away
from the main house
um
and
yes security were there also
all right sticking with the caretaker
just briefly um about how long would it
take would you estimate it would take to
walk from the main house to the
caretaker's house
under five minutes i mean
yeah
no more than five minutes
okay
and then you mentioned security what was
the security setup security was set up
um by jerry judge
they they were employed they stayed in
the grounds for the duration they didn't
come into the house they had a little
sort of shack where around by the
perimeter wall
where they would do that start their
patrols from walk around the grounds
around the exterior of the house
at certain times of the day
write their reports and
go back and stay in their their shack
and how many security guards would be on
site at any particular time i think one
in the day and one in the night so they
did 12 hours about as i remember it but
it was 24 7. yes definitely okay
uh do you know whether those were were
local employees or were they regularly i
believe they were they were australian
yes
okay
now i think you said you were not on the
property 24 7 right you had an apartment
elsewhere correct yeah i i kept the same
hours as i
did in london essentially you know
monday to friday nine to five not quite
but seven eight a.m till
evening till everything was set up and i
could leave
okay
and did you have an opportunity when you
were in australia um to observe mr depp
and miss turd's interactions with each
other yes of course
and how would you describe them
initially very good
like in london that seemed very
pleasant towards each other
did you observe any arguments
yes
i've several
okay can you tell us a little bit about
those
um yes
a similar pattern it seemed to london
arguments
uh one in particular was
very similar to the the second one in
london
uh
started in a
in the tv room funnily enough
um
loud loud voices
and uh mr depp leaving the room
shutting the door going to another room
to play his guitar or you know to a
bathroom whatever
um and miss her closely following and
opening the door or certainly wrapping
on the door
it seemed to continue
giving us an estimate um about how many
arguments you think you observed in this
time frame approximately several i mean
we were there for several months so
certainly many more than in london
did you observe any alcohol consumption
in australia by either of them
yes again misheard
i was again
my response part of my responsibilities
was to provision the house and have
everything set up for that so i
i regularly brought red wine
for miss herd
which she consumed
you know the same same amount as in
london i think
and what amount of speaking
one or two bottles a day
okay
did you ever observe uh
mr depp start any arguments with miss
hurt
no
hold on oh sorry yeah could you put your
mark up there we go leading objection
leader oh sustain is deleting if you
want to go um we can move on new
question okay
um
do you remember anything about uh friday
march 6th 2015.
it was
essentially a normal friday if you like
um
end of the week
yay
um nothing extraordinary about that day
did you come into the into work that day
yes yeah i was there
okay
um
do you recall about what time you would
have left the house uh on that date i
remember taking a photo of a of the
beautiful sunset over the pool the sun
would set over the pool and the the
creek
i took a photo of that around early
evening so
6 30 7 i would think i wouldn't have
left much later than that
was mr depp there when you left
i don't think so i think mr depp was at
the studio still
on that day i can't remember sort of
seeing him to say goodbye
you know have a good weekend
how about miss her do you recall if she
was there when you left yes she was okay
did anything unusual happen that weekend
but yeah i would say something pretty
unusual
happened can you tell us about that
yeah i can foundation
all right foundation you want to lay a
foundation
at some point did you become aware that
something had happened
between
all right
i'll sustain that objection
all right turning to the following
sunday this one is how much more do you
have because it's time for our afternoon
break
uh i think we
i
can
i have a little bit more your honor so i
think maybe this could be a good time
for everybody all right let's go ahead
and take our afternoon 15-minute break
ladies and gentlemen again do not talk
to me by the case don't do any outside
research okay your excuse thank you
so
okay
all right we ready for the jury
all right
so
all right you have a seat your next
question sir
thank your honor
mr king uh
before we went on break
we were discussing uh
friday march 6th 2015. right
after you left
uh the house
that evening
when did you when did you next see miss
heard
sunday the eighth
and where
did you see miss hurt
at the house
what were your typical
hours monday to friday from 7 or 8 a.m
until
the end of play each evening early
evening usually
why were you at the house that sunday
i was called to the house by one of mr
depp's assistants
and about what time
did you arrive at the house
around 2 o'clock 2 30
who was there when you arrived
um debbie lloyd was there
david kipper was there
amber heard was there
jerry judge was there
and i think i think by now probably
everybody's familiar but can you just
very quickly say who those
who those people are sure
uh debbie lloyd was a nurse
david kipper was dr david kipper
ms hurt was misheard and
jerry judge was
head of security
and when you arrived at the house
on sunday march 8 2015
what did you do
i just popped up and went into the house
and did you observe anything when you
went into the house
yeah i mean initially i walked into the
front door i initially i heard
rather than
saw
anything i could hear
pretty hysterical sobbing
crying
which sounded like misheard to me
i heard jerry judge's voice
there's a few steps as you go up into
the house so you can't immediately see
what's going on but so i went up the
steps i could see then misheard over on
the right hand side
of towards the tv room with jerry judge
david kipper was in the kitchen
area which was pretty much directly
ahead as you walk up those steps
and were you able to
visually see miss hurt
yes
and you were able to hear her as well
absolutely
how would you describe her demeanor
hysterical
probably the best way to describe it
crying a lot and
you know
just just crying uncontrollably i think
it's fair to say
and how would you describe
jerry judge's demeanor when he was
speaking with her i think he was just
keeping her calm
saying it's all right love it will be
all right you know jerry was good like a
big heart jerry he's a good guy
he was
he was calm
jerry was always calm well mostly
and what did you do next
um i saw they were
engaged across a way there so i went
into the main kitchen area which as i
said was just directly ahead of those
main steps and spoke to david kipper
and following that conversation what did
you do
well he told me that um
mr dep had
objection hearsay all right
uh your honor it's
well maybe approach okay
so you can answer the question what what
did you do next
so i spoke to david kipper
who was in the kitchen area
seemingly rummaging through a bin
um he said he was that mr depp had
sustained an injury to his finger one of
his fingers and he was looking for
the fingertip that that it said it had
been severed
so i said i said well should i help you
you know as one would
and
he said yeah that would be a good idea i
left him in the kitchen he said there
was a lot a lot more damage downstairs
so i i went to you know we split up he
was left him in the kitchen i went
downstairs
to to search
uh at some point was mr depp's fingertip
found
yes
who found it
i did
and where did you find it
downstairs in that the bar area
the um
the games room bar area
so can you
walk us through
how you found it
yes so i walked down the stairs uh i
mean there was a bit of damage down the
steps that big chunk had been taken out
of the marble staircase um on my way
down with remnants of what looked like a
plant pot or something around it smashed
walking down into the bar i could see
the damage that dr kippur had told me
about
a broken ping pong table sort of
collapsed onto the floor
and lots of glass and broken glass and
cans strewn around the bar area
and where exactly was the finger in the
bar area
directly below the bar i mean the bar
set up like a conventional bar
that stuck out from a wall
and
that with a marble top there's a big
chunk out of that as well like on this
staircase
directly at the end of the bar
there was a scrunched up piece of
kitchen paper if you like tissue um with
lots of blood around it on it
so i thought that was probably a
pretty good place to look
and it it was within that scrunched up
piece of paper
on the tiled floor at the end of the bar
the base of the bar by one of the bar
stools
was there any property damage around the
finger
yes a fair bit
on the floor around the area the puddles
of what smelled like alcohol to me there
were
seemed like several drinking glasses a
couple of
bottles one was a stolikniya vodka
bottle
[Music]
and at the end of the bar on the as i
said there's a big chunk out of the bar
itself the marble top
uh at the end of that the bar
there was plaster damaged
right at the end of the bar on the wall
uh behind the bar that smashed and
cracked
mirror there's a blue mirror
that stretched that whole span of behind
the bar
lots of cans again behind the bar on the
floor
broken window at the end of the bar
and more plastered work damage on the
wall above the sink is sort of a
kitchenette bar if you like as well
you mentioned a
bottle of vodka was the vodka bottle
intact
no no nothing was really intact but the
top of it
you know the top of a bottle was like it
had a label on it which is how i knew it
was a stolic now bottle had that sort of
squiggly yes
um sort of yellow top
there was a large chunk of a bottle
which i guess was the rest of that
and several other i mean lots of other
broken glass around the area
after you found the fingertip in the bar
area
what did you do next
well i gathered it up in that kitchen
paper
and sort of took it upstairs i might
have shouted up to david kipper i found
it i'm not sure but i i walked back
upstairs to the kitchen
and
put it
got a bag you know a little um
little plastic bag put the fingertip in
there set it on top of some ice in in
this plastic kitchen container and
pretty much handed it over to david
kipper and jerry judge i think at the
time who were keen to get it to the
hospital quickly
to see if it could be reattached
do you recall about what time you found
mr depp's finger in the bar area
it was about an hour after i got there
so it would have been around 3 30 i
would think 3 20 3 30.
okay
now you've told us a little bit about
the state the house was in when you
arrived
yes um
can you generally
describe for us and maybe go level by
level through the house
um
what damage you observed
sure do you want me to start at the
lower ground floor in that bar area i
mean i've described a lot of that
sure it was pretty extensive down there
all that broken glass the blood a lot of
blood drips across that floor is a kind
of cream-colored tiled floor
in that whole games area as i said the
ping pong table was
collapsed
blood drips
across the floor and around the bar
and the damage on the walls as i said
the plaster
work at the end of the bar behind the
bar
and
the the chunk out of the marble top
so on the ground that was the
predominant damage in that in that area
on that level on the next floor on the
main floor where david kipper was
and
be in the kitchen itself again
a few broken glasses and cans on the
floor
soda cans behind the
kitchen island
the chef's kitchen island
liquid sort of puddles
there was a sitting room with a couch on
a cream-colored couch which had a fair
amount of blood
drips on the cushions and
that you know that was obvious
the
tv which was directly in front of that
wall-mounted tv was cracked with it
seemed like remnants of a coffee cup
embedded in some of it and the rest was
below looked like coffee spattered
behind and underneath
the tv
and on the floor as well
uh through there would set up an art
studio
so a lot of the art materials
from that you know paint brushes paint
uh various art materials were on the
floor a lot of paint on the floor
blood drips throughout that area as well
especially over the there's a vast sort
of wooden parquet floor there was a lot
of oil paint and blood drips
up to the staircase
in one of the bedrooms there were two
bedrooms off of off of the main kitchen
area one of those bedrooms had
blood drips on the duvet
and a lamp
had seemingly been broken the champ the
shade was removed
uh
there were a couple of lampshades in
that in the
art studio area
on the floor
uh that was about the extent of the
damage going upstairs to the next level
there was
a few blood smears on on the wall
and on the
drips
of the stairs going up again a
cream-colored carpet which not ideal
um
and so that's the top floor was the
master
bedroom master suite
floor and two bedrooms also up there
outside the master bedroom there was
damage to the plus to work on the on a
pillar outside
on the wall
blood drips into the master bedroom
across the master bedroom floor
going into the master bathroom
um
there was
there was a his and her sink and
a mirror a large mirror above each of
the sinks that had writing on on each of
them
again that one of the bedrooms or both
of the bedrooms i think had blood on the
duvet
covers
and another lamp was broken
mr depp's guitar was in one of those
bedrooms
with a bloodstained guitar
his ipad was standing up on
one of the
beds in in one of those bedrooms
that's i mean that's about the extent of
it
that's the damage on each level yeah
whose job was it to clean all that up
that was mine
that was my
my responsibility the house was
essentially my responsibility
so you were familiar were you familiar
with the damage generally throughout the
house i got a pretty good idea as i
walked around and
saw it all yes
did you observe any damaged phones
no
uh did you observe any damage to a wall
where a phone might have been ripped off
the wall no
bleeding
oh yeah right maybe the next one
was there any artwork in this house
decorating the house the owners had left
their art in the house yes
the
mr depp and miss heard had done some
artwork themselves yes
but
yes there were there was some that came
with the house if you like
focusing just on the artwork that came
with the house
did you observe any damage to any of
that
no nothing that i needed to
repair or replace certainly not
thank goodness
is there any other damage that comes to
mind
just a lot of blood a lot of repairs the
floor as i said was
um quite heavily
with blood and
paint yeah
and in in terms of
bodily fluids it was just blood that you
observed no urine or anything else
yes absolutely i'll sustain
strike the answer from the record
no other damage does any other damage
come to mind no
okay
can we take a look at defendants exhibit
375
which i believe is already in evidence
and can we publish this to the jury okay
mr king are you familiar with the image
that's on the screen in front of you
uh yes that's one of the mirrors i was
telling you about in the master bathroom
and so
were you involved in cleaning any of
this up
i cleaned both of those mirrors at some
point that that evening that night
yes
were you able to tell what was used or
what what substance the
i guess what sort of the ink is that's
used on the on the black writing there
that was the the same
um oil paint that was on the floor on
the parquet floor downstairs and various
other places was the same
oil paint
all right how about the red writing that
says call star call carly simon
she said it better babe
were you able to tell what was used to
make that writing a lipstick foundation
foundation he's testified that he was
cleaning it up
that's fine
it certainly seemed like lipstick to me
red lipstick it was quite waxy i
remember taking that off um
it seemed like lipstick
okay we can take that down
mr king about how long were you at the
house
on on that sunday
quite a long time
it actually went into the early hours of
monday morning so
at least i got there around two in the
afternoon of sunday
i don't think i left there until
two or three o'clock the next morning of
the night
over the course of the time that you
were there
that day
did you have any interactions with miss
heard
yes i certainly did
can you describe those for us please
yes uh not too much initially she was
very as i said quite hysterical and
crying a lot and jerry judge was taking
care of of her keeping her calm
later in the evening
it was
it was suggested that miss her go to a
local hotel
to to leave the house go to a local
hotel which then became a suggestion
that she go back to la
and that's i think when i started
interacting
in terms of at some point i volunteered
to to travel with her to l.a
how did miss heard respond
to the suggestion that she leave uh los
angeles leave for los angeles
she was resistant to both of those
suggestions uh very resistant she really
didn't want to go and
said i can't leave i can't leave
you know it'll be the end if i leave
those sorts of things
and so it was just it
these went went over a few hours um
those negotiations if you like
and
eventually misheard agreed that i would
fly with her
and did you in fact fly with her
i did on monday the 9th
okay
sticking with sunday um
when you were interacting with her on on
that sunday
um were you
how close were you to her
very clear you know like
very close in front of her
and do you recall observing any injuries
on this hurt
no none whatsoever
did you notice anything unusual about
her physically at all
no
i mean she was obviously crying a lot
with red eyes and
um but
no otherwise no
okay
so what happened the following day that
that monday uh march 9th i guess it
would be 2015. right so
i mean it was eventually agreed that i
would fly
with misheard so i
i had to at some point go back to my
apartment drive to my apartment to pick
up my passport which funnily enough i
hadn't brought with me
and some clothes you know a bag to take
so i think i i left the house early
hours as i said two three may have been
a bit later
a.m
i drove back to my apartment which was
30 minutes drive south
picked up those things
i mean i didn't know what i was how long
i was going to go for but i knew i was
traveling so passport quick shower pick
up a bag of clothes
and i drove back up to the house
i don't recall exactly what time i
arrived there but i know we had to leave
all the arrangements will be made by the
travel agent and jerry judge was
liaising with them to make the flight
arrangements and which i believe was
going
mid mid to late morning
so i think we had to leave the house
around 7 or 8 a.m that morning
monday the 9th
and did you travel to the airport with
ms hurt
yes
yes we were driven
how would you describe her demeanor that
morning
um calm down a fair bit
um
she was mostly on the phone to be honest
for
for pretty much the whole of that car
journey
to various people one of which i believe
was mr depp
do you recall her saying anything on the
ride to the airport about what had
happened to the night prior nothing
really
mentioned in that as way as an
explanation now
what happened when you got to the
airport if anything
we were running a bit late but i i
remember that um
luckily we were traveling first class so
the driver knew to to pull up to a
a kind of vip for one of a better word
vip
check-in point um
and so the car got pretty close to where
the desk was
miss herb was still on the phone
and so i we sat there for a bit with the
driver and
ms heard was talking
i don't know who to at that point
and i was thinking uh we need to make
this flight actually pretty soon because
we're already running a bit late
so i decided to go in maybe i can go and
check in our bags ahead and
then come back and get misheard she
should be finished by then which is what
i did
and did you eventually get on the plane
eventually we did it was a close call to
be honest
once you were on the plane um
did you have any conversations with herd
yes i mean not not initially which took
some time in the bathroom she was on the
phone again to the point where the cabin
crew had to sort of tap on the door and
say uh we need to leave now everybody
needs to sit down
and she did come to sit down that you
know after 10 or 15 minutes in there
and so eventually and luckily as i said
we were flying first class which was
lovely
she was in the window seat like i think
is one a1b
window seat i had the aisle seat
and uh finally
we could both sit down and
um in way of conversation wasn't a great
deal to be honest i did sort of say
finally so what happened
you know obviously referring to the
house
and
i mean she didn't give much explanation
if any she did say
um ben have you ever been so angry with
someone you just lost it with them
um
and i sort of said uh no
actually i'm pretty calm you know even
tempered guy um
but she did repeat it she looked pretty
incredulous that i hadn't and she
repeated it you mean you've never lost
it
with somebody got so angry with someone
you just lost it with them
and i said unless you count the sort of
time when i was 14 years old and i
hit the light switch in my bedroom
because i wasn't allowed out that night
or something with a person no never
that was pretty much the end of the
conversation she dropped it then
how would you describe her tone
when she asked those questions of you to
me
incredulous would be fair to say
surprised that i hadn't
lost it with somebody
does anything else stand out about that
flight
it was fairly cut after that it was calm
but i mean we were both exhausted um
i certainly was and
that i think it's i can't remember
eating even just
slept most of the the flight
until obviously we landed or close to
landing
at any point did you observe anything
about mister physically on that flight
yes i did
right toward just before we landed i
noticed some marks on her
on her arm her left
forearm
how would he describe those
um
long
kind of uniform evenly spaced sort of
long thin
marks
very uniform in fact
and when did you first notice those
on the plane towards coming into land
you know gathering the stuff up i
noticed them then
what did you do after you landed in los
angeles
once i'd fired up my phone um on landing
uh i saw the arrangements that we would
be picked up by one of mr depp's
security
personnel who i i think was travis
mcgivern my governor mcgivern
um
so
i made contact with him and he met us in
the place that had been arranged
we walked through the you know the
arrivals lounge and met him at the end
of that
got in the car with him
and uh drove to the eastern columbia
building
and how did miss heard how would you
describe miss heard's demeanor in los
angeles
yeah pretty calm i mean um
she seemed
i mean obviously a lot calmer from the
house but
she pleasant towards travis certainly in
the car obviously they knew each other
um
she was we when we got to the building
she was kind enough to show me around
the the apartment i'd never been before
she showed me around the penthouse a
little tour
she wrote down some restaurants
recommendations
because she knew i'd be staying a few
days
probably
so and i didn't i don't really know la
that well
so she recommended a few restaurants
and i and then
i i left i said if you need anything as
usual as i always did need anything give
me a shout i'll be staying fairly close
by
just just give me a call or a text
how long were you in l.a
uh less than a week i think i flew back
to australia on the 14th or 15th
so about five days six days tops
and when you got back to australia
what were you doing
pretty much putting the house back
together
um repairing all the damage with the
help of professional contractors vendors
um i brought in
and
just getting the house back
as it as it was originally
at some point did mr depp and miss herd
return to australia
yes they did
um were you there when they when they
returned yes
did you observe them interacting with
each other after they came back to
australia yes yeah
and how would you describe their
interactions
again initially those first few days
were certainly very pleasant almost
honeymoon like i would say
it strolled around the grounds a bit and
they seemed seem fine with each other
did you ever observe any arguments after
they returned
yes i mean many
several more yeah
and how would you describe those
not dissimilar to the london arguments
in terms of the pattern of those
you know that sort of provocation and
the reaction that
leave the room mr that leaving room
going to another room playing his guitar
seemed to follow the same pattern as
that
as i witnessed those two times in london
all right
nothing further
all right cross examination
good afternoon good afternoon
um
so
to understand your testimony is it your
testimony that amber and mr depp arrive
together in australia in february of
2015.
initially i
together i don't think so i think mr
depp arrived at ahead of
actually mr depp arrived first correct i
think so yeah and isn't it true that
miss heard amber didn't arrive until
march 5th 2015 to australia i can't
remember the date she arrived to be
honest but she could have arrived march
5th 2015. isn't that true objection
foundation speculation i'll allow it if
you can answer it
sorry what was the question miss heard
could have arrived on march 5th 2015
correct
it's possible i suppose and isn't it
true then that you didn't see any
arguments between ms hurd and mr depp
before the injury that occurred to mr
depp's finger
in australia
i saw them argue you saw them argue when
they came back
when they came back in april correct
i certainly saw them arguing
in april and through most of the months
they were there yes but you but you
don't remember you can't recall any
arguments in february or march of 2015
between ms heard and mr deb correct
specific days
not necessarily no right so that you
don't know you can't say that there were
any arguments before you came to the
house on march 8th 2015. correct i think
there were i mean
excuse me say that again i think there
were
but you don't even know when she arrived
correct
specifically
that the day uh not necessarily no okay
and you said when you arrived at the
house on march
8th
um when you eventually found the finger
it was wrapped in paper is that right
wrapped i mean it was loosely wrapped
the paper would open by that point that
the blood had dried up and it was
sitting in in the sort of nest of this
paper yeah so like someone had put the
finger in a piece of paper
i i i don't know i mean it was in that
piece of paper it was in a piece of
paper okay so but again like someone had
wrapped it up is that right
i don't know it was within that
scrunched up piece of paper kitchen
paper tissue it was in kitchen paper is
that right
tissue paper it was white with a lot of
blood on it so like a paper towel like a
piece of kitchen towel
can you say kitchen towel
our language is made even though we both
speak english i may stay a little
different like a paper towel
um yeah like kitchen paper kitchen towel
yes okay like a tissue and was there
that sort of paper towel in the in the
kitchen at the house at the time
yes in both
areas of the kitchen and
the bar
okay
um
[Music]
you said you were in
australia starting in february of 2015
correct correct i arrived on the 4th of
february and mr depp arrived some time
after that is that right correct okay
did you see um marilyn manson while you
were there
no i didn't you don't know if mr depp
was with marilyn manson
in early late february early march 2015.
objection foundation to speculation
relevance i'm just asking if you saw if
you he said he saw how he said he saw
him every day so i was asking
i'll allow the question if you can
answer it as well marilyn manson didn't
come to the house i i didn't see
him at any point do you know if mr dapp
left to be with marilyn manson
i don't know i didn't always know where
he was going if he was went out it was
either to work or the security would go
with i wouldn't generally go
in fact i don't think i went out with
him at all in australia and they were
you didn't go out with mr deb at all
when he was in australia correct i don't
recall it i went to i saw him on set
once or twice yeah so you don't know
what mr depp was doing in australia
unless he was unless you saw him at the
house or on set is that right
i saw him at the house yes every day but
you don't know what he mr deb was doing
when he left the house correct generally
going to work on pirates of the
caribbean five philly yes but you were
you were with him
no but the security with him and i had
to liaise with him for when he would go
and when he would come back for the
driver et cetera but you weren't there
you weren't there when mr depp left the
house correct
generally i didn't go i didn't leave the
house with mr depp on those days no and
i just want to make sure i want to be
clear there were there were two kind of
periods that mr deb was in australia in
2015 right
sorry again mr depp was in australia
from
sometime in february 2015 until
about march 8th march 9th
when he injured his finger is that right
correct yeah and then
mr depp left australia too correct
at some point he flew to l.a yes
and then mr depp returned to australia
on april 21st
right
okay that sounds about that time i don't
know the specific date i don't recall
and the filming of pirates of the
caribbean five continued filming on
april 21st right objection foundation
speculation i didn't oh sorry there's
objection
you recall testifying to that in the uk
that
the filming of pirates of caribbean five
continued filming on april 21st 2015.
i wasn't involved in the filming
schedule i didn't know what when it
resumed to be honest
i knew mr deputy come back to to resume
filming for sure
you didn't live with mr depp in his
house in australia correct
live with that no i wasn't resident
there
now
when you arrived at the house
you saw a significant amount of damage
correct
yes through the course of yeah after i
arrived yep okay and you were you the
scene was chaos correct
chaos i mean there was a
fair amount of damage the house was
wrecked
there was a lot of damage in the house
yes and the house was not in a good
state correct
there was a lot of damage throughout
that
objection go ahead next question okay
and
um
there you said there was glass on the
floor correct
in a few areas mainly predominantly in
the bar yes down in the lower ground
floor correct okay and there was blood
on the walls correct
in various places that
blood on the floor blood on the walls
and there was blood on the walls
throughout the three stories of the
house isn't that right
um no i wouldn't say that was the extent
of it there were smears up the staircase
going up to the master from the main
level there were smears and drips on the
carpet so there were smears from the
master level up to the up to the bedroom
area
i mean comes from the main level up to
the bedroom area is that right up to the
third floor yes like someone had walked
from the
main floor up to the bedroom floor
correct there was blood going up the
step up steps
on the staircase and some on the walls
you know smears where you might have
done that as if someone was walking from
the main level
up to the
master bedroom correct is that what the
blood was like
yeah maybe i don't know
okay or down
i mean up or down from the main level to
the up from the main level to the third
floor correct
correct yes
um
and you said the sofas were damaged is
that right
one surfer in that sitting room which
was just off the kitchen was quite an
open plan thing so off that there was a
sofa
with a large tv on the wall-mounted tv
in front of that sofa and the sofa was
on the main level correct correct just
by the the main kitchen exactly where
the sofa was damaged was that with with
what blood blood okay and there were
lights were damaged
some lamps a couple of lamps yes okay
and
there were bottles of alcohol in and out
of the fridge correct
sorry what do you mean did you see
bottles of alcohol in and out of the
fridge
yes um i mean there was
i don't
i don't completely understand what you
mean
there was alcohol bottled yes there was
in the fridge i
i mean named it being a bottle of wine i
don't know
and and the floors were ruined correct
ruined i mean there was a lot of damage
on the floor on the down in the bar area
and the staircase and
on the main floor area in the wood
wooden parquet floor correct and the
floors are going to have to be sanded
correct
i eventually got them sanded yes okay
and it took
you were there i think you testified it
took you about 12 to 13 hours in the
house cleaning up correct correct okay
and you said that there was
is it your testimony that you didn't see
any of the paintings damaged
the existing paintings from the the
owners from the house that
no none of them were damaged you didn't
see any paintings with a painting of a
penis drawn on it
i did not and thankfully i that was
something i wouldn't didn't have to
replace
do you know anyone else
objection speculation i mean
i would have seen it where there's
objections okay you just need to stop
that's all right
all right if you stand we can see you
better when you do that understand okay
i'll sustain the objection next question
okay
and you said that jerry judge was at the
house correct correct and he's the head
of mr deputy security correct correct
and dr kipper was at the house yes he
was and debbie lloyd was at the house as
well correct yes she was okay
now
you understood that mr judge saw
scratches on miss hurt on march 8th
correct objection hearsay speculation
foundation
all right i'll sustain the objection
next question um
did you have the cleaning lady was going
to be coming to the house correct the
housekeeper yes the housekeeper adele
the resident housekeeper
yes she was going to be i mean yes she
was employed through the week again she
wasn't there on weekends there was
concern about the cleaning lady coming
to the house and seeing
everything that was in the house correct
objection speculation uh foundation that
baby if he can
there was concern about the cleaning
lady coming to the house and seeing all
the damage that was that had been done
correct
i know that when i left to
fly to l.a with miss hurd i told both
the chef and the housekeeper they didn't
need to be coming to the house um
because missouri that essentially the
principals weren't there mr depp wasn't
there miss heard was obviously with me
at that point so i said they didn't need
to to come to the house
isn't it true that you told mr judge
that you thought you could get the
cleaning lady to swear to silence about
what the house looked like
production hearsay
it's his own statement his own statement
allow it
isn't it true that you told mr judge
that you could thought you could get the
cleaning lady to swear the silence about
what the house looked like
i think i probably
made
a comment about
you know i should just come back and
deal with this myself
if that's what you mean and just get
cleaned up and make sure that she
wouldn't say anything correct
i don't know we trusted
i trusted her and the chef anyway they
were good
good team team members as the house
manager part of your job is to you said
you worked with um
high profile people correct
high profile high net worth i think is
what i actually said
would you agree that one part of your
job is to keep things discreet for your
clients of course it's part of my job
trust and discretion yeah and mr depp
was your client right
i'd
worked on an assignment
on those occasions yes but i was
self-employed at the time but in
march 8 2015 in australia mr depp was
your client correct correct essentially
yeah
and misheard both of them the principles
and you know
how who paid your for your services
as i said before i was paid through
disney who were making the pirates of
the caribbean their production company
which i believe was called her shell
okay
and can we put up defendants exhibit 377
um
which is already in evidence
mr king do you see defendants exhibit
377 in front of you i do yes
and
do you recognize this as
a lampshade that was in the house in
australia on march 8 2015.
yes it was i believe one of the
lampshades that was missing from one of
the lamps okay and and you saw did you
see this uh painting on the on the
lampshade
i did yeah it was part of my walk around
and what floor was the lampshade on
this was on where the art studio was on
that main level yeah so on the main
level okay yes um
excuse me
and was this was this uh did you notice
it was
dark paint that was on the lampshade
it certainly looked like it yes okay
um and did you take this picture
i believe i did i yeah without seeing
the metadata but okay
and can we put up defendants exhibit 374
please
and you
recognize uh defendant's exhibit 374 as
a mirror that was in the house in
australia on march 8 2015. correct
yes i do
and this mirror was in the bathroom
correct
correct there were two mirrors in the
bathroom above each sink and this was on
the the top floor correct the master
bathroom
and the master bathroom just so unclear
was on the top floor
correct and this uh painting said
starring billy bob is that is that right
is that what you recall
um
yeah i didn't know i was writing okay um
and was this was this in
uh the writing was it in paint
i believe it was the same
paint the oil paint that was used on the
other mirror that we saw earlier okay
and did you take this picture
again possible i haven't seen the
metadata but
yes probably and and let's put back up
defendants exhibit 375.
this this writing was was also in the
master bathroom correct correct yeah
okay
and could you tell if the black paint
was on top of the red or or
under the red
i didn't really analyze it to be honest
i just knew i was going to have to clean
it up at some point right your whole
concern was just cleaning up clean
cleaning up the house correct correct
okay
and you don't know who wrote what on
this
on the mirror correct
no i know that one was oil paint that
and the other red writing was lipstick
and lipstick you're not even sure of
that you just saw it was
something sticky is that right i'm
pretty sure it's waxy you know
lipstick like um same as the oil paint
was
oil paint like okay
did you see paint did you see also
any writing in blood
um writing no no not necessarily okay
now
did you help when when miss heard was um
leaving to go um
back to la uh you were you were with her
correct correct did you help her pack
i think i may have done at that point
yes i think i did did you see were
weren't weren't miss hurt's clothes
ruined
i didn't see any ruined clothes there
wasn't paint on her clothes
i could see not so much um
yeah
not not that point of packing i mean
there was paint in the tub correct say
again sorry there was paint in the tub
in the bathroom correct
i don't recall that you don't recall one
way or the other
i don't recall being paint in the tub
and it's your testimony that there was
no pain or blood on miss hurt's clothes
is that what you're saying
out loud okay
[Music]
now
um you you said you were in charge of
the cleanup correct
yes it was my responsibility
the house was
and you were
working with
mr with mr judge and
um
cleaning up the house is that right
um then the night that i the day that i
arrived there yes mr judge did help me
at some point yes sweeping up glass etc
and we're that we're there
was there
photos taken of more than the three
three pictures you've been shown
photos photos of the house
by whom
did you take any pictures of the house i
took a few yeah i mean
yes and
did you take pictures other than the
three that we saw
i think i probably did as i was going
around do you know who you gave those
pictures to
no do you know what you took the photos
with
my phone
and who would you have sent those photos
to and send them to anybody at that
point you just kept them
yes did you show the photos to anyone no
do you still have the photos
yes
they're on you they're where are they on
your phone still
they're on one of my devices yes okay
did you take um a photo of the vodka
bottle that you said was broken
yes
and you have that photo
yes okay and you didn't but you didn't
give that to anybody
there were a fair few photos i can show
it to you now if you want how many
photos did you have on your phone
i don't remember the number but
probably more than 10.
did anyone ever ask you for the photos
several of them yes i was yes did you
give them to did you give them to the
people who asked
some of them yes not all of them
i don't recall how many who asked you
for the photos
um
i was involved in
in a case
in london a couple of years ago
did you give the photo of the vodka
bottle to the people
that you were involved in the case in
london objection relevance your honor
overruled a lot
say again sorry did you give a photo of
the vodka bottle to the people you were
working with in london i didn't recall
which photos i it
sent
given
what other so did you take photos of
um
the walls
the walls that certainly the smears
on the blood and the damage the plaster
damage yes you took so you took photos
of the
walls with blood on it is that right
yes and you took photos of the plaster
right that was damaged
at the end of the bar under in the bar
behind the bar by the sink yes and did
you take photos of the um ping pong
table that you said was broken
yes as part of the bar area i'm sure
take photos of there was a glass table
that was broken too correct
a glass table i didn't recall a glass
table okay
did you take photos of all the damage
that was around the house
probably most of it yes okay and
the only time you gave those photos to
anyone you're saying was in the
uk case a couple years back i'd never
shared them with anybody else yes okay
and it cost between
it costs about 75 000 to clean up the
damage isn't that right
i don't know the exact cost that i think
we i calculated at the time you know
after all the vendors had been in done
their things it's about 50 000 i seem to
recall
okay
now
[Music]
you
you said you
flew back to to australia with ms hurd
correct
i didn't fly back with me flew back to
la from australia thank you with mr
correct correct okay
and you were asleep for most of the
flight correct
a lot of it i think it's a 14-hour
flight so i think we both slept for
quite a lot of it yeah
you were exhausted from the 13 hours you
were working on the house right correct
all right
and your testimony was that ms heard
said to you have you ever been so angry
with someone that you just lost it
correct after i'd asked so you know what
happened but you didn't you you didn't
inquire as to what she was referring to
right
i i mean
by what happened it was pretty clear
what i was referring to
let me ask again you did not inquire as
to what she was referring to did you
with her answer
correct
she didn't inquire as to my reason for
asking but it was pretty obvious to both
of us what i was asking and what her
reply was regarding
yes that's fine sir thank you
thank you
mr king you testified on behalf of mr
death
in the uk correct
correct
okay
and you provided two witness statements
correct
correct
and then you provided
testimony
in court correct
correct okay
and
if you take a look
at
page 1103 of your testimony
you see how the pages go in fours
yeah
no
you see it's actually on the um bottom
right
bottom right you see that yeah got it
and if you actually look at um
you see starting at the bottom of 1102
there's this was a statement when you
said you did not um
you say miss heard asks you have you
ever been so angry with anyone that you
lost it your answer that's correct
and you specifically remember that do
you yes
you said it never happened to you
answer that is correct question she did
not i mean
it was if it was said nothing was said
about who she was talking about was it
answer she was asking me a question
question she was
asking you a question answer yes
question you did not inquire as to what
she was referring to did you i did not i
do not recall asking
i know that she was asking for a
question and i gave her an answer you
see that
yes okay and that was your testimony you
gave in the uk
uh two years ago correct
yes okay
so you don't know what and you don't
know what miss heard was talking about
when she made that statement correct
you don't know if she was inquiring that
she was making that statement about mr
depp right
like i said i'd ask the question what
happened referring to the house
um
and she gave me that answer so i think
we were both
it was pretty clear to both of us what
we were talking about
i mean yeah and you went to sleep at
that point
and then you went and then you went to
sleep and then you had the flight the
rest of the sometime after that yeah
okay
um
now
and you said you saw him
misheard with cuts on her arm is that
right
right towards the end of the flight yeah
okay
if we could put up 376 g
do you recognize
this picture
i've not seen this picture before
were these the were these the cuts
did you see cuts like this on miss herd
is that miss head
why don't we put up 376 c
do you recognize the person in that
picture
that's miss hood all right and did you
see cuts like that which are on her
left arm
similar to that long like i described
earlier long thin cuts um pretty uniform
cuts these were the cut
it was the cuts were like this on her
kind of wrist forearm area is that right
i don't know what the date of this
photograph is but they look pretty
uniform like they do here yes okay
i'd like to enter 376c into evidence any
objection
uh no no
3760 in evidence
and can we put back up 376g
seeing 376c is as consistent with the
scratches on 376g or these consistent
with the scratches you saw in this herd
i didn't see a date is that the same
time is that the same date oh that might
i mean my question is are the scratches
similar to what you saw on this hurt
these are uniform kind of long thin
scratches yes because i like that
scratches 376g into evidence any
objection i mean foundation he hasn't
authenticated the document through this
witness
are you i'm just asking if the pictures
are consistent with
376g
and can you publish it please it is
thank you
okay
now
you were in the
house you said for 12 to 13 hours on
march 8 2015 correct
correct going into march 9th 2015.
okay and you
spoke to mr judge when you were in the
house correct
interaction with mr judge yes and you
had interaction with dr kipper
when you were in the house correct
correct
and you had interaction with debbie
lloyd
when you're in the house correct yes
briefly
okay
and isn't it true that in the entire
time you were there
you were not informed as to
what caused damage to mr depp's hand on
finger on march 8th objection hearsay
i'm asking what he wasn't told
i'll sustain the objection next question
you didn't know what could cause damage
to mr depp's hand while you were there
on march 8th correct
doctor kepler told me
he sustained an injury on one of his
faces objection here's hearsay
you asked the question
okay he said he sustained an injury to
his finger yes but you don't know what
caused the injury one of his fingers
but you don't know what cause you don't
know how his finger was injured i don't
think anybody mentioned it to me at that
time right no one mentioned it to you at
that time correct
the same objection you're hearsay
now you understand that there was um
a phone in the house that was recording
during the cleanup correct
sorry i didn't hear all of that did you
come to understand that there was a
phone in the house that was recording
as people were cleaning up
um at that time no
but you now you now know that there was
a phone that was
recording
people as they were cleaning up correct
objection foundation hearsay
i'm not asking for a particular
statement that's just fine out loud if
he knows
i believe that came up somewhere later
on at that time i wasn't aware but i
believe i became aware of it later yes
okay
um i would like to
put up
defendants 378
it's a recording
and i want to play a couple of times
1207
through 13 19.
is that the only
only segment you wish to have
and then i would also use
i'd also like to play 1951 through 21
38. and is is this going to be used
again or is this
um i i think it would be a okay 378 any
objection to 378a yes your honor we do
have an objection i believe this is a
recording that has the voices of people
other than misheard and mr dev and on
that basis it's hearsay okay unless i'm
incorrect about which document we're
talking about
excuse me sorry about that um going back
to the
photos that you took for a moment
of that damage in the house you recall
giving that testimony yes okay did mr
depp ask you for the photos
no
did you give the photos to counsel for
mr depp
some of them yes yeah did you withhold
any photos for mr depp or his council
and withhold any photos from
from anybody
i didn't withhold did you give all the
photo did you give all of the photos you
have on your phone to mr deaf and his
counsel not all of the photos on my
phone now all the photos of the damage
that occurred on
march 8th 2015. probably not all of them
i don't think so
you didn't give them all you didn't give
them all to mr deputies council i don't
believe i gave all of the photos
[Music]
why not
because there are a decent amount of
them but i mean
so you picked and you chose what photos
you want to give to mr deaf and his
counsel i
i gave
an amount of photos to them
do you know how many photos you gave to
mr deputy's council i don't know
precisely no okay
can you give an estimate as to how many
photos you gave
i really can't no
you know an amount i i don't recall how
many
more than three
yes more than ten
possibly more than 10 yeah
yeah maybe between 10 and 20
objections
do you know sorry i she overruled you
okay um
possibly more than ten yeah
so but somewhere between 10 and 20 is
that right possibly i honestly don't
know could it be more than 20
i don't think so did mr did mr death's
counsel ask for all the photos
i i didn't recall
you don't recall one way or the other
what they asked for
i gave them some photos
i i don't recall how many or how many
were asked for requested and those were
those were requested
in 2020
correct prior to
prior to the uk that yes
did they ask for him in this case
i believe i supplied
some for this case also yeah you
supplied photos for this case to mr
depp's council
i believe i did okay and was that about
the between 10 and 20 photos that you're
talking about i don't remember how many
for this
but it was it the same was the same
amount of photos that you gave to the
count the mr depths council in the uk
i don't know if it was the same amount
i didn't i don't recall did mr depp's
counsel in this case ask for all the
photos you had of the damage
of
march 8 2015.
all of the photos i don't think they
requested all of the photos
they didn't ask for all the photos you
had of that damage
i
don't know if they requested them all
okay
was it mr waldman who asked you for the
photos
originally i don't remember who called
shillings
were they
did mr wallace ever ask you for the
photos
i don't know if he asked me specifically
if he was part of the that team i
i assume so
and you spoke you spoke you spoke to mr
waldman is that right
i did a couple of years ago yeah okay
and and he was part of the team that was
asking for the evidence you had
of what occurred in australia in 2015 is
that right he was part of that team as i
understood it yeah okay and as part of
that team he would he and others were
asking for all the we're asking for
photos from australia from march 8th
2015. is that right they requested them
at some point sometimes and you provided
and that's when you provided the
10 to
is that 20 photos correct okay and then
was there a separate council that asked
you for the photos in this case
uh yes
there was yeah i mean it was essentially
the same
who was it that i asked you for photos
in this case i don't recall a name
specifically was it a man or a woman
part of the team i didn't recall okay
and when did they make that request
when i i don't know a date i don't know
specifically you know what year
um
this year last year i mean prior to this
obviously so it could have been in 2022
that they asked you for the photos uh i
think it was prior to that
i didn't recall so
maybe late 2021 or early 2022 is that
what you're saying i honestly don't
recall which part of the year but in
either 2021 or 2022 is that right i
would imagine that's probably correct
okay
and you get and you gave them all you
gave them
some of the photos you had as i just
said yes okay but not all of them
correct so do you have more than 10 to
20 photos on your phone of the damage
that occurred in australia again i
didn't recall it the amount
but you have a larger amount on your
phone than what you provided to mr
depp's council objection your honor ask
and answer cumulative i'll sustain the
um
going to london for a couple minutes you
didn't you didn't live at the house in
london correct i didn't live there
correct okay
do you know if miss hurd had friends
over uh to the house in london
she did they came to state um
yes and they stayed for they stayed from
september 9th through september 22nd
2014. correct
i don't remember the duration but that's
that's possible okay and they were
staying they were they were literally
staying at the house correct
they
were accommodated at the house correct
right
and so
you don't know who was drinking the
bottles of wine that
were brought into the house correct
at which point
what do you mean when miss hurt's
friends were there you don't know who
was drinking the wine oh they were all
enjoying the wine they were all drinking
the wine
i took care of them as i would take care
of any guests that came into any house
and wasn't it five to seven guests that
were at the house with misheard i don't
remember the number it sounds about
right okay and then and then at the end
of the night there was one or two
bottles of wine finished right when mr
depp and misheard were there on their
own there was certainly that amount yes
but do you know how many you don't know
how many
you don't know how many battles were
there when it was miss herd and her
friends correct
i'd say more
you don't know but you don't know one
way or the other right i don't recall
the count but certainly more
than when there were just two of them in
the house because you don't know seven
extra people or five people oh you don't
know the count
precisely no i don't and you do you know
how much time has heard was in london
with mr depp not with her friends
a fair amount of that time i don't
recall days no i don't recall so they
were there for a month correct
thereabouts yeah and i mean when i say
they miss
heard and mr depp were in london for
about a month right correct around about
a month and wasn't it true that for
about two to three weeks
ms heard's friends were also staying in
london i don't think two or three weeks
i i don't recall but i don't think it
was that long you don't know one way or
the other right i didn't think it was
that long but you don't have anything to
base that on right just your what your
memory is saying correct okay
and
you don't know what happened in london
when you weren't there correct
you mean after i'd left for of an
evening yeah
usually the chef was there still when i
left each evening russell um who would
take care of dinner and leave later that
each night and then after they the chef
left you don't know what happened in the
house correct
i wasn't there right
and you don't know for certain whether
mr depp drank wine or not in london
right
i don't believe so there's usually when
it was just the two of them in the house
there was usually only one glass in the
morning either on the kitchen sink or on
the bedside stand in the master bedroom
but you don't know who drank from that
you don't know who drank from that glass
when you weren't there right well i
wasn't there correct but when i usually
left the house i'd already poured miss
heard a glass of wine before i left
invariably but once you left you don't
know if mr depp drank wine or not
correct
i wasn't i wasn't there when i after i
left okay
um
and you don't know what started the
fights you talked about in london
correct
other than that one you said you heard
about
her hand the second one that i described
i was in the vicinity i heard the first
comment of this that was the start of
that argument and you don't actually
know if there was an argument before
they before what you heard right
of that evening i didn't hear another
one i'll put it that way it started in
that room as i described earlier
and and you don't know what happened in
australia also between march 5th and
march 8th correct
the 6th i left on friday the 6th was
when i left for the weekend okay so
between friday the 6th and when you got
to the house on march 8th you don't know
what happened and i wasn't there okay
and you
never saw miss heard be violent at any
time right
sorry again you never saw miss heard be
violent at any time correct
beyond sort of fingerprinting and
violent i didn't see it either would be
violent towards each other you never saw
miss heard be violent at any time right
i couldn't see her be violent
depending on your
i can show you a witness statement where
you said you never saw miss her be
violent at any time okay violence if yes
i didn't see violence per se
okay
all right thank you i have nothing all
right thank you
mr king have you ever been employed by
mr duff
no
so in each of these situations where
you've been around mr depp you've always
been employed by somebody else
correct all right without sustain is
leading let's strike the answer next
question
are you based anywhere other than the uk
where do you where do you live i live in
central london have you ever lived
anywhere else
[Music]
we heard some discussion
on cross about photos which i suspect
you remember
um
why did you take the photos of the
property damage in australia
as i do and a lot of my jobs into
various assignments and jobs
through the years
i take photos as points of reference
for whatever reason i mean if i'm
packing
suitcases up um and they're going to be
in transit and i'm not with the
suitcases i'll take a picture of
contents and
when i send stuff so i know it's gone
and what's gone um i take pictures as
points of reference i sometimes take
pictures of
table settings that i've done or
which i know
i can use later on to as a reference
were the photos of property damage in
australia the first photos that you've
taken um in the course of
um
working with mr deaf and ms heard
objection leading all right i'll sustain
us deleting next question had you ever
taken photos before yes
um how do you take what kinds of things
have you taken photos of
um
in london reference points and
dinner table settings um
sometimes
mr depp would write notes for miss heard
he'd leave notes
[Music]
on the on the sort of kitchen table when
he left for work
i believe i took pictures of those they
were
you know there things like that
just setups of once i set up houses it's
always good to take photos of
rooms so so i can cross-reference later
on if i need to
did miss heard or her counsel ever ask
you for photos of any of the photos you
took in australia no
all right
i'll stain is deleting next question
can i see plaintiff's exhibit 159
and i think this is a multi-page
document can you
scroll through
i think we have three pages here
mr king do you do you recognize
this this uh document
yes it's the floor plan of the house in
australia
and do you recall on on
cross-examination you were asked to kind
of describe where some of the property
damage was yes
so
right now
on the screen in front of you
yeah um
which floor would you say this is this
is the top floor the master suite and
two other bedrooms
okay and i believe council asked you um
if there was blood in one of the
bathrooms or one of the bathtubs do you
recall that
yes they did ask that would that have
been on this floor
i i i think that we're referring to the
master tub i think that's what he said
okay so can you mark on the on the
screen where that would have been
the master tub
it's over here can i just dot it how do
i just start it yes
okay so that
looks like the master tub to me
and just uh to clarify did you did you
recall seeing any any blood or damage
there in the tub now okay
can you mark for us on the screen where
you did see the damage that was
discussed on cross
the mirrors um what can i dab on here
again oh sure yeah so these are the
sinks the two mirrors were above each of
the mirrors above each sink
okay
can we
can we scroll up uh to the page prior
and can you point out for us on on on
this page well first of all which which
floor is this this is that the main
level floor essentially the
second floor if you want
okay
and can you point out for us here on on
this map uh which of the
where where the property damage was
yes
how many dabs am i allowed
around here
kitchen area
this was the tv the wall-mounted tv
on
i ran out of dabs
i apologize actually your honor can can
we move this into evidence um any
objection to 159 no objection all right
159 in evidence can we publish this to
the jury okay
so mr king i apologize for interrupting
you so you were just pointing out where
on the i think this is the second floor
yes essentially the main level yeah
okay so other than these three dots do
you recall any other places where there
was damage yes where it says family
family room uh there was a the tv was
wall mounted
on that that wall in between family and
lounge
the sofa was approximately where you've
got the red square uh red
red rectangle now
facing towards the tv
uh the lounge is used sorry
too too quick
the lounge was essentially the
um art studio
and the bedrooms over to the left there
where the lamp
damaged lamp and
shade blood on the uh duvet etc that i
described
okay and then let's go to the first page
and which floor is this
this is the
lower ground floor
okay and can you point out for us um did
you find the finger on this floor
correct can you point out to us where
you found the finger yes i can
right here
ah
there we go
it's the end of the bar it was on the
the tiled floor
below that end of the bar
okay and any other significant property
damage that you want to point out on
this
on this floor
yes as i said though
this was the uh can i dab again yeah so
that was the the most part of the broken
glass that's where the stolic nia bottle
was below that bar by the bar stores
there were three bar stools
um that you could sit at there
on this back wall
here there was plaster damage
on
over here above the sink
or to the side of the sink was more
plastered damage on the walls
behind the bar
that mirror was cracked broken
uh
ping pong table was around there
collapsed on the floor
and around those three dots then i'm
gonna put another one that was the
spillages as well that
smelt like alcohol to me the puddles of
alcohol
[Music]
i mean that that was the
the most part of the damage around that
area
um in front of the bar especially
there was i mean as i said there were
blood drips around that white
cream-colored tiled floor
in the in the game's room
and this is the staircase down is this
side that that the chip was out of the
the stone step
and if i can get another dab in there
right about in the center of that bar
the chunk out of the side of the
of the counter bar top
okay
um
how many exits are there on the ground
floor
well all of these were where exits you
know all these um
my office was off over here i think you
can just see how it says study
big glass sliding door
uh the gym had an exit
up here this went into the garage there
was a
button you could press for the automatic
doors to come up
the
laundry area which is right here that
this
this is actually an exit
out into the yard essentially
[Music]
um the gym
all of those rooms had a had an exit
[Music]
okay
um other than uh
other than mr depp's council did anybody
else ever ask to see your photos
i'll allow it
no
all right
nothing further your honor all right
just witness subject to recall
all right so since you're subject to
recall it's important that you do not
discuss your testimony with anybody and
do not pay attention to the trial and
don't watch anything about the trial
okay of course all right thank you
all right you can step down sir yes
thank you
ladies and gentlemen that comes to the
end of our day so we're going to excuse
you for the evening again do not do any
outside research and don't talk to
anybody and we'll see you tomorrow
morning okay have a good evening all
right thank you
all right and just have one housekeeping
matter you uh we're going through the
exhibit you gave me this morning thank
you again for that but one of them was
485 and i have my notes that was 485a
just the first page but you gave me all
eight pages have you both agreed that
all pages of this document come in or is
that something that
should i give 485 back and you can try
again to give it back to me tomorrow
okay all right i'll give that back to
you and we'll see
what happens tomorrow
all right
thank you all right and are we going to
start with a remote witness tomorrow is
that going to be your first witness
all right make sure she's signed on by 9
40 so we can have it all set up for 10
o'clock start okay
all right
do
do
do
you